안녕하십니까 챔피탄 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리
모닝브리프 7월 2일 목요일 순서
시작하겠습니다. 7월 첫째 날은
어떻게 중국이 마감했는지 왕정부장님과
함께 알아보겠습니다.
>> 네. 어제는 경기 민감주 선상하면
상시주 플러스 2.44% 올라왔고요.
홍콩 시장은 효정입니다.
>> 음
>> 어 정시 과대면 3.7조 외양까지
올라왔습니다. 업종별 좁으시면
테스키어 금융 부동창 업정인 건세
배웠고 반면는 커뮤니케이션 IT제
업정이 약세 배웠습니다. 거래대금
상승 그리고 대행화 피오 기대감으로
금융주 어금 반등 나오고요. 공신
증관은 이중이 5% 올라고 동방
재보는 5% 고대 해동는 5% 종신
강도는 3% 올라왔습니다.
>> 범주도 같이 성상했어요. 중국 인수
법은 9.7% 중구는 3.8% 신화
법은 거의 상한가 결했습니다.
어 소비제 관련수도 돈반하고요. 그의
임. 6% 우량에는 0.7%요.
과가 매수 자극 유입으로 헬스케어 권
관련주어제도 선성했습니다. 선서
제한은 3.3% 만서 1는 4%는
0.6% 스 나왔어요. 어제 전 초반
그대 반도체 되게 좋고요. 그 후반는
살짝 좀 내려갔습니다.
>> 아마 선승하는 주시는 몇 가지 좀
나왔어요. 반도세 장비주들이 좀
강하게 올라왔습니다. 북방 화는
5.7% 어때 추가적으로 올라갔어요.
그 역사 신고 냈습니다. 영소 대비는
104% 정도 올라왔어요. 이번에는
랑기 테크는 1.9% 전테크는 3%
하의 층과는 2.4% 자는
올라왔습니다.
어제는 글로벌 주요 MLC 업체는
예선대로 가격 인상했습니다.이
소식으로 MLC 관련주는 것에
올라가고요. 화 증자는 2%에 올라고
통화테크는 3%에 굴아왔습니다. 요가
하라 등으로 항공주어제도 강세
보였고요. 중국 고장 항공 3% 중군
동방 항공 3%에 올라왔어요. 태별한
거는 2분기 태배 기업들이 어제 실적
나왔어요. 그래서 태배 권용조들이
어제 올라왔습니다. 천번 홀딩스는
3% 올라왔지만 운통 태배는 10%
신통 태배는 10% 윤달 태배는
8%으로 나왔습니다. 반면은 PCB
광통신 관영주 어 다 빠졌어요.
승인테크는 -5% 호전 주시는
-5%에 빠졌습니다. 신염물 구세
금리 어 1.3bp 상승했습니다.
은염물 구세 금리는 염정 2bp
상승하고 외한화 확 환율은 염정
05% 정도로 소포 자화되었습니다.
감사합니다. 어, 쭉 얘기를 들어보면
제가 중국 시장을 몇밀히 본 건
아니지만 한국 시장하고 전체적인 장애
색깔은 유사했다 이렇게 보여지는데
그렇게 생각했던 두 가지 이유가
첫째는 어, 한국도 어저께 전반적으로
뭐랄까요? 종목 확산이라고 표현해야
될까요? 그 반도체 중심의 일변도였던
시장의 어떤 리더들이 조금 그
리더십이 조금 쓰러지면서 그동안 많이
하락했던 그런 종목들로 매기가 좀
옮겨가면서 어 어저께 한국 시장 같은
경우 증시가 하락했기 때문에 옳은
종목은 많지 않았지만 지수 대비 상대
성과 관점에서 보면 반도체보다 어
[콧방귀] 좋은 상대 성과를 낸
업종이나 종목들이 좀 많아졌다. 그런
생각이 드는데 앞선 쪽에서 말씀해
주시는 거 쭉 들어보면 헬스케어 금융
부동산 뭐 이런 것들 쭉 보면은
반도체 혹은 IT 오를 때 이제
쉬었던 업종들인데 이런 쪽이
상대적으로 어 좋았다는 말씀을 해
주셔서 비슷하지 않았나 생각이 됐고
두 번째로
>> 한국도 어저께 삼성전기만 세서 그죠
기판이나 MLCC 관련주들
>> 그런 부분도 좀 특징이 비슷했다라고
생각이 되는데
>> 제 이해가 맞습니까?네 네,
맞습니다. 어제 우리는 어 제가
매일매일 체크했는 그 콘테주로 지표중
있는데요. 어제는 시전은 세차 좀
약세로
봤어요. 왜냐면 그 상식 임등 44%
밑으로 가면 처음 맨너 2%
빠졌잖아요. [목을 가다듬음]
>> 그래서 확습되었어요. 다른 그 선승한
정무수는 전날 부단을 훨씬 많이
올라왔습니다.
>> 예. 그리고 52시적으로 보시면 다
에티입니다.
>> 음.
>> 네. 주가는 빠지지. 빠져 정종에
그냥 역사신 것이 거의 남이
있습니다.
>> 음.
>> 원래 이렇게 너무 이렇게 시장
주도주가 가파르게 과열되면 주변으로
좀 확산됐다가 거기 어느 정도
마무리되면 다시 또 시장 주도주가
올라가고 하는데
>> 그럼 우리
>> 왕박사 모델에서이 다시 시장 주도주에
관심을 받아야 될 때 알려 줘요.
[웃음]
알겠습니다.
>> 네. 어저께 어 택배 기업들 아 택배
업종 시작 아 저 어떤 발표치가
있었다고 얘기했는데 준비해 주신
종목도 그런 거 같습니다.네
>> 완동태배 어제는 10% 좀
상한가로였습니다. 실전에도 나오고요.
어이 홀사는 지금 시간에
12조원 되고요. 좀 크지 않습니다.
포드 피안는 여덟배 수준입니다. 중후
태배 시장 MS 125%로 2회로
유지했어요. 어 잠정 실적
발표하고요. 한반기 수익는 동의부터
85.7% 증가 예상입니다. 역선을
하면은 2분기의 순위 있는 동의.
2%부터 89.2% 2% 점
이상입니다. 그래서 정강값
기준으로 하면은 컨설비 12% 정도
상회였습니다. 어 배달수 증가 그리고
ASP 가급가 반등 비용 관리 강화
등 따라서 허실전을 달성했습니다.
1월부터 5월까지 중국 그 태백 산업
총 어 태배 건수는 동기 대비
5.2% 증가하지만이 호산은 배달
검수는 9.7% 7% 증가했습니다.
그래서 시점보다는 높은 수지를
발생하고요.
>> 특히는 정년 2분기보다 원래 2분까지
ASP 증가율 계속 계산되고
있습니다. 정년 2분기는 동의. 3%
3분기는 - 2.4% 4번기는 -
1.5% 원래 1분기 지문 1월부터
5월까지 하면은 프로스 0.1%
전환되었어요.
2번기는 페달 건 검 건당 그
순위기는 어 전번기 대비는 22.7%
동기대비 80% 정도 증가했어요.
2022년 1회 최고치했습니다.
>> 그래 화증 리포츠 좀 나왔습니다.
현후 ASP 추가 상승 그리고 시전
정면 확대 등에 따라서 실전는 우상형
지수 예상입니다. 매수 위을 유지하고
올래 부담 내년 내년 EPS는 각가
1.9 2.1 2.4 외한 정도로
추정되었고 동일 대비는 51.2%
147% 14.7% 7% 10% 정도
증가할 수 있어요. 타켄은 올해는
13배 PR를 적용해서 TP는
24.8 위한 종시였습니다.
어제 종가 대비는 또 58% 업세
나올 수 있어요.
>> 네. 감사합니다. 택배 산업 우리가
자주 보는 업종은 아닌데맞네.
>> [콧방귀]
>> 어, 한국하고 좀 비교를 해 보고
싶은데요. 한국 같은 경우 택배
산업은 무체국 택배라고 하는 어떤
공공 기관에서 하는 택배 업
>> 포함해서
>> 어 대한통원 등등해서 몇 개
[콧방귀] 한
>> 세 개네 개 다섯 개 정도가 형성하고
>> 잘은 모르지만이 현금흐름 그러니까
에비따 기준으로 보면은
>> 어 이익을 낮은 수준이지만 내면서이
꾸준히 가는 걸로 그렇게 형성됐다고
알고 있는데
>> 중국도 어떤 중국은 어떤 상황인지가
궁금하고 만약에 네.
>> 그렇게 [콧방귀] 이제 몇몇
업체들끼리 어 좀 나누어서 어느 정도
이렇게 낮은 마진을 유지해 가는 그런
상황이라면 기업은 솔솔히 돈을 벌고
있지만 주가 [콧방귀] 관점에선
우리가 주목을 해야 하나라는 의문점은
생기긴 하는데 오늘 이렇게 소개시켜
주신 목적이 뭔지 좀 궁금합니다.이
>> 원통 태배는 약간 군에 있는 한진태배
피는고요.
>> 네. 어 과거 몇 명년간은 그
코로나시기지나 후에는이 업계는 균
되게 심졌어요. 그래서 가는 더
솔로는 공교적으로 잉하하고
>> 그래서 적자까지 내려가는 건 아니지만
거의 그 BP 수준 내려갔어요.
그래서네 맞아요. 안 되는 회사도
스슬 많이 나오고
>> 근데 뭐 2024년 2025년
초대되는 정보가 정책을 바꿨어요.
이거는 뭐 어 뭐 비상적 뭐 그 증정
이런 걸 하지 말라고 하고 그래서
정년 2번기 그때부터는 받아치고
AS를 계속 올라갔습니다.
>> 아마 지문 효과가 좀 나오고
있어요.음
>> 2 3분기나 2분기 3분기 4분기는이
부분은 ASP는 추가적으로 계산
가능성이 있다고 생각해요. 왜냐면
공급당이 이미 그 뭐 이미
자연되었어요. 조금은 수요 회보에
따라서이 ASP 가격을 올라갈 수
있다고 생각하고 있고 특히는 이런
회사들이 계절성 요인이 되게
심하고요. 제가 좀 통계던 분위가
이런 태배 업체들이 항상 3분기
그대는 주가 수익률이 되게 좋고요.
그래서 사고 싶으면은 지금 사는 절
같습니다. 음.
>> 어. 어. 어저께 어떤 분이
주식
>> 네.
>> 투자를 할 때 큰 비중을 사지 못하는
주식. 네. 트레이딩 개념을 약하게
좀 사보는 주식을 간식이라고
표현하던데네.
>> 어 그렇게 이게 좀 약간 트레이딩
개념으로 볼 수 있는 업종이나
종목이다. 그 정도 이해하면
되겠습니까?
>> 예 맞습니다. 바로 간신하십시오.
[웃음]
>> 네. 알겠습니다. 어 현금 비중은
높은데 살 종목이 좀 보이지 않을 때
이런 종목들 관심 가져보자. 그런
차원으로 소개시켜 주신 종목으로
이해하고 넘어가 보도록 하겠습니다.
네. 전일 미국 시장 보겠습니다.
아침에 뭐 뉴스나 이런 것들 보니까
좀 분위기가 안 좋은 거 같던데 어떤
내용들이 있었는지 우리 유리프로와
함께 알아보겠습니다.
>> 네. 어, 말씀 주셨듯이 어제 한
9시 10시 그쯤부터 해가지고 제가
계속 핸드폰을 보고 있었는데 빅
이슈가 하나 있었더라고요. 이제 메타
아무래도 다들 주목하고 계셨을 것
같은데 그래서 오늘은 메타 그리고
AI 출론 학습 이런 뭐 키워드
위주로 좀 설명을 드리고자 하고 아마
이제 부사장님께서도 뒷부분에 이제
관련해서 좀 더 스페시픽하게 언인
꼴이나 이런 거 분석하면서 말씀해
주실 걸로 알고 있습니다.
>> 네. 예.
>> 네. 그래서 일단 수요 미국장은 지수
자체로만 먼저 보시면은 좀 소폭
조정적으로 마감을 하긴 했습니다.
근데 이제 내부적으로는 메모리랑
반도체 장비주가 좀 함께 밀리면서이
AI 인프라 랠리 시장치 분위기
전체를 좀 그동안 이끌어 왔던 어
키워드였던 AI 인프라 랠리에 좀
균열이 생긴 하루였다라고 보실 수
있을 것 같습니다.
지수 쪽부터 먼저 보시면은 주요 지수
모두 하락 마감했습니다. SP 뭐
장중 52주 신고가 찍히는 했는데요.
장 후반으로 갈수록 반도체랑 에이어
인프라 관련 종목들 차익 실현이 좀
커지면서 이제 막 좀 하락하면서
마감했습니다. 다도 이제 장중
신고가를 기록하긴 했는데 사실상
보건으로 마감했고 나스닥은 반도체
약세의 영향으로 이제 좀 하락하면서
가장 크게 마감을 했습니다. 다만
오늘 지수 자체보다는 좀 내부 흐름이
훨씬 중요했던 하루다라고 이제 말씀을
드렸는데 우선 이렇게 매크로 환경만
보시부터이 점검에서 탑단으로 내려가
보시면 주식 시장이 그렇게 나쁜
환경은 아니었거든요. 유가 쪽 먼저
점검을 항상 드렸는데 이제 유가부터
보시면 오늘은 차트를 가져진지
않았지만 WTI 기준에서 한 68달러
대까지 이제 내려오면서 이제 중동
쪽에 리스크 프리미엄이 좀 이제 좀
신경을 쓰지 않는듯한 그런 흐름은
보여줬고 또 장중에 발표된 ISM
제조업 지표도 시장에 그렇게 큰
부담을 주지는 않았습니다. 이제 6월
ISM 제조업 PMI가 나왔는데 이게
53.3이라서 3이라서 6개월 연속
확장 국면을 이어갔거든요. 하단
텍스트 보시면 되는데 이제 PMI는
50 넘기면 좀 경기 확장을 뜻하는
지표이기 때문에 지표 이거 이제
동시에 투입 가격 지수는 좀 크게
하락하면서 비용 압력도 좀 하
완화되는 흐름세 보여줬습니다. 그래서
이제 성장은 아직 버티고 물가 부담
좀 내려오는 그래서 다시 이제 주식
시장에 좀 우호적인 환경이었고요.
이제 고용 관련된 보조 지표도 좀
발표가 있었는데 좀이 지표 자체도 좀
급격하게 뭐 주식 시장에 냉각이 있다
이렇게 시그널링 해 주지는
않았습니다. ADP 민간고용 6월 달
이제 9만8,명 증가하면서 컨센서스
소 하락하긴 하회하긴 했지만 이제
감챌린저 감는 전널 대비해서 좀 크게
줄었습니다. 그래서 뭐 고형이 다시
강해졌다라고 보기는 어렵겠지만 좀
급격한 해고 사이클로 번지고 있다라고
또 보기도 어려운 흐름이어서 이제
전체적으로는 또 완만한 둔화에
가까웠습니다. 또 이제 한편으로 좀
튀었다라고 보여진 지수가 제가
하이라이트 드렸던 소파금이
부분인데요. 단기 그 자금 시장에서는
소파랑 IRB 스프레드가 3BP로 좀
양수 쪽으로 올라왔습니다. 그래서
소파 뭐 국채 담보로 이제 하루짜리
현금 빌리는 비용이고 IRB는 뭐
연준이 은행 지급 준비금에 지급하는
금리잖아요. 그러다 보니까 이제 소파
금리가 좀 우떨하다는 거는 레퍼
시장에서 좀 단기 현금 조달 수요가
좀 강했다라는 뜻이라서 뭐 이번 그
3비P는 분기말 대차대표 관리랑
레버리지 포지션 조정에 가까운 그래도
기술적 압박에 가까운 수준이었다라고
보이고 여기 이제 좀 그래서 결론은
뭐 유동성 스트레스 신호로는 보이지
않는다요 수치가 이제 그렇게 해석
해석을 했고 그 여기에 이제 어제이
신트라 포럼 한 포럼에서 이제 워시가
인터뷰와 발언을 했었거든요.
그래서 여기서 이제 그 나왔던 워시
의장의 발언도 시장에 뭐 크게
부담스럽지는 않았습니다. 워시는
물가가 여전히 높은 수준이기도 하고
뭐 2% 물가 목표 포기하지
않겠다라는 점 분명히 하긴 했지만 뭐
최근에 인플레이션 위험 관련해서의
언급은 좀 위험은 낮아졌다라고 언급을
하면서 좀 어 시장 자체에 뭐 완전
긴장감을 주는 발언은 하지 않았다
정도로 이제 해석을 할 수 있을 것
같습니다. 그래서이 발언 자체 뭐
금리 인하 신호다라고 보기는 어렵긴
하겠지만 적어도 이제 주식에 추장하는
이제 시장 입자에서는 인플레이션이 뭐
다시 완전 통제 불가능한 수준은
아니다 정도로 볼 수 있을 것 같고
전반적으로 이런 지표들을 다 랩업해서
보시면은 매크로 자체만 놓고 보면
오늘 장이 주식에 크게 불리한 장은
아니었다. 뭐 유가도 내려왔고
제조업도 확장 공지했고 고용도
완만하게 둔화가 됐고 단기 자금 시장
뭐 압박도 단기 자금 시장도 좀
일시적인 수준 압박 수준에 그쳤다.
근데도 이제 지수가 밀린 이유는 그럼
왜 그럴까 생각해 보면 매크로가
아니라 그럼 AI L리라는 키워드의
좀 문제였다 정도 이렇게 좀 내려와
볼 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서
이제 그 주인공이었던 메타를 이제
말씀드리려고 하는데요.
여기서 이제 중요가 이제 어제
8.8% 8% 상승을 하긴 했는데
동시에 이제 약간 반대 끝보에
있으면서 많이 하락했던 종목들이 아래
언급들이 코어위브 그리고 네비우스라는
네오클라우드 이제 사업자들이었습니다.
그래서이 지표들에서 이제 극명하게 볼
거는 아 메타가 코비랑 내비우수 사역
구조를 빼웠다라기보다는
어떤 이제 그 인프라가 중요해졌고 그
안에서도이 컴퓨팅 장비가 어떤게 다
팔렸 팔렸기 때문에 향후 이게 빅테크
쪽에서 어떤 움직임을 보여 줄 수
있을 것인가를 좀 해석해 보는게
중요할 것 같은데
>> 그래서 사실이 메타가 주가으로 왜
올랐을까를 생각해 보면 메타가
클라우드 사업 관련해서 추가적으로
업사이드가 있다라는 걸 보여줬기
때문에 시장이 반응했다라고 생각을
하거든요. 근데 여기서 좀 중요한
거는 뭐 메타가 클라우드 사업을
한다. 그래서 앞으로 더 돈을 잘 벌
거다라기보다는 추자 입장에서 좀 두
가지를 나눠서 봐야 될 거 같은데
이제 첫 번째는 그 컴퓨트
판매거든요.러 컴퓨트라는게 진짜 날것
그대로 연산 장비 인프라 이런 건데
이거는 이제 GPU 서버 용량 자체를
좀 외부에 빌려 주는 방식입니다.
그래서 쉽게 말하면은 AI 계산용
서버를 이제 외부에 빌려 준다라는
건데이 경우에 이제 메타는 코어이브나
네비우스 같은 네오클라우드랑 직접
경쟁하게 되는 구조입니다. 그래서
네오클라우드가 그동안 이제 돈을
벌어왔던 방식이 AI 학습이랑 출론에
필요한 이제 GPU 인프라를 빌려
주는 구조였기 때문에이 부분에 있어서
뭐 그 메타가 메타가 이제 앞으로
우리 GPU를 대어해 준 서비스를 할
거야. 이제 코입 내비우스 필요
없어라고 한다면은 이제 그들과
직접적인 경쟁을 하는 거고 그게
1차적으로이 주가에 반영이 됐다라고
생각하고요. 근데 그 두 번째로
넘어가서 생각을 해 보면은 이제 메타
자체 모델이 이제 올라간 인프라
접근권을 파는 방식이 또 있는데 이건
좀 사용자가 모델을 직접 내려받아서
돌리는게 아니라 메타 인프라 위에서
돌리는 모델을 접속해서 쓰는
구조거든요. 그래서 이건 좀 어
아마존의 AWS 베드럭이랑 좀
비슷하다라고 보시면 될 거 같은데
그래서 이제 클라우 A 그 AWS
베드럭처럼 클라우드 안에서 AI
모델을 호출를 쓰는 방식이랑
비슷합니다. 좀 복잡한 그 단어들을
말씀을 드렸는데 좀 나눠서 생각을 해
보시면 오른쪽에 이미지 보시면
되거든요. 이것도 이제 클로드를 써서
한번 이미지를 단순화 시켜 봤는데 어
이미지 보시면 왼쪽은 학습 그리고
오른쪽은 추론이거든요. 학습 같은
경우는 모델을 만드는 단계. 그래서이
안에서는 뭐 대규모 GPU 클러스터가
필요하고 H100이라든지 200 뭐
그 B200, GB200 같은 고성난
GPU가 좀 중요한 단계입니다.
그리고 이제 오른쪽에 넘어가서 보시면
여기도 이제 마찬가지기는 하지만은
핵심은 그럼 어떤 9세대 인프라가 좀
처분이 되는 거고 어떤 인프라가 또
새로 들어오냐요 부분을 좀 주목해서
보셔야 될 거 같은데 여기서 이제 좀
중요한 거는 메타가 그 판매하겠다고
하 그니까 그 클라우드 시장에
진출하겠다고 하면서 처분하겠다고 한
이제 연산 인프라가 무엇인지가 좀
핵심 쟁점이 될 거 같거든요. 근데
만약에 여기서 9세대 인프라를
팔으로써 앞으로 우리가 출론 단계로
나가겠다라고 하면은이 클라우드 매출
자체가 좀 정당화될 수가 있는
부분이고 그게 아니라 이걸 다 갖고
가면서 추론 인프라까지 이제 확대하는
구조가 돼 버린다라고 하면은 뭐 지금
단계에서 우리의 비즈니스 모델이 돈이
안 되고 있기 때문에 새로운 쪽으로
이제 확장을 해야 된다 정도로 이제
해석을 해 볼 수 있을 것 같아서
여기서 구체적으로 어떤 인프라를
앞으로 판매할 거다라고 이제 뭐 말
언급을 향을 해 줄 것인지가 좀 어
핵심 질문이 되지 않을까라고 이제
보여집니다. 입니다. 그리고 만약에
이제 부형 인프라를 판매하지 않고
계속 갖고 간다라고 했을 때는
네오클라우드에는 직접적으로 경쟁
부담이 될 수 있다. 근데이 부분은
차치하고서라도 향후 그런 메탈 주가의
업사이드가 이어질 수 있을 것인가를
이제 판단을 하려면은 학습이냐
추론이냐 아니면 확실하게 업사이드가
더 있느냐 그리고 그 넘어서 이제
빅테크 쪽에도 그럼 이게 영향을 끼칠
수가 있을 것인가가 좀 핵심 쟁점이
될 거 같습니다.
네. 그래서 이제 빅테크 쪽도이어서
보시면은 좀 상대적으로 강한 흐름세
보이긴 했는데요. 메타가 가장 강하긴
했지만 마이크로소프트도 이제 3%
올랐고 애플도 상승 그니까 아마존
구글도 좀 상승하면서 기록을
했습니다.이 뭐 단순히 위험
선하기보다는 뭐 AI 인프라 투자를
좀 감당할 수가 있고 좀 클라우드
매출을 좀 하고 있는 회사들인데이
인프라들을 좀 제품화할 수 있는
플랫폼 기업들의 프리미엄이 붙은
흐름이었다라고 보실 수 있을 것
같습니다. 반대로 아래쪽에 이어가서
보시면 좀이 흐름이 1차적으로 시장에
부담이 됐다라고 인식이 됐던 것은
반도체였는데요. 이제 마이크론이
10% 가량 하락했고 샌디스크도 이제
10% 가량 하락을 했습니다. 근데
메모리랑 좀 메모리 장 반도체
장비주도 좀 같이 빠졌다는 흐름이 좀
중요할 것 같은데
이게 특정 뭐 메모리가 좀 뭐
프라이스가 많이 올랐다라고 요즘
시장에서 많이 회자되는 그런 가격적인
측면보다는 장비조가 같이 빠졌다는
점에서 AI 밸류체인 자체가 좀
챌린징을 받기 시작했다라는 일차적인
흐름으로 좀 보실 수 있을 것
같습니다. 다만 여기서 이제 가져가야
될 생각은 앞으로 투자를 하실 때 뭐
반도체 하락이 있다. 그래서 A수가
붕괴됐다라기보다는이
메타가 향후 어떤 연산 차원을 이제
판매할 것인가 그래서이 빅테크 쪽에서
벌어들이는 쪽이 어떤 곳이 될
것인가를 이제이이 기업들에서 이제
발표하는 뭐 앞으로의 제품이라든지 그
로드맵이라든지를 좀 트래킹할 필요성이
있을 것 같습니다.
>> 이제 반대로 이제 그 헬스케어 쪽이나
섹터 쪽 보시 섹터 쪽 보시면은 좀
순남매가 좀 지속 좀 흩어진
장이었다라고 보실 수 있겠는데요.
신고가 쪽은 제가 오늘 여러 개
분산에서 넣어 놨는데 이제 금융주에도
신고가가 있었고 헬스케어 그 그리고
이제 소재 쪽으로도 좀 확산되는 흐름
보여줬습니다. 그래서 뭐 시장 자체는
앞서서 매크로시퍼 드렸듯이 우호적인
주식 시장 자체는 우호적이었지만 그간
이제 많이 올랐기 때문에 차익실환
부담이 있었던 AI 반도체 메모리 주
장비주까지 있었고 있었다는 점을 좀
특기할 만하다라고 이제 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 오늘
이것저것 말씀을 많이 드렸는데 결국
오늘장 핵심을 좀 남기자면은 이제
하반기 시장의 질문이 좀 바뀌는
시점이다라고 좀 저는 생각을
했습니다. 그래서 왜이 시점을
하필타가 발표를 했을까가 저는 오늘
좀 더 궁금하긴 했거든요. 추후 이제
부서장님께서도 말씀해 주시긴
하시겠지만은 하반기부터는이 인프라가
실제 매출로 회수되는지를 보다 이제
더 명확하게 보기 시작했다. 돈을
버는 기업, 돈을 뭐 쓰는 기업
이렇게만 이제 나눴다면은 돈을
벌어들이는 기업 안에서도 그 기업이
정말 돈을 벌 수 있을 것인가로
질문이 좀 더 이제 들다됐다라고 보실
수 있을 것 같고 메타가 이제
하반기를 새로 시작하면서 그 AI
인프라 랠리 관련한 새로 질문을
던지는 스타팅 포인트가 되었다라고
보실 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 음.
>> 네. 말씀을 쭉 줬고 저도 아침에
보니까 메타 주가가 8% 이상
올랐다. 그리고 마이크론 10% 이상
빠졌다. 뭐 이런 헤드라인들만 좀
봤는데 어 일차적으로 어떤 생각을
했냐면 어 이렇게 어 데이터 센터
AI 관련한 투자를 해서 앞으로 돈을
벌려고 하는 기업들이 메탈를 중심으로
어떤 새로운 아이디어나 어 전략
방향이 나오면서 어 메모리를 덜 쓰는
쪽으로 이제 가나라고 하는 굉장히
단순한 생각을 했었거든요.데 데
유리프로 얘기를 쭉 듣고 보니까 제
생각이 약간 바뀐 부분은 어
돈을 써서 이제 돈을 벌어야 하는
그니까 투자를 해서 돈을 벌어야 하는
기업들이 하반기에 어떻게 돈을 벌지에
대한 방향성이나 아니면 구체적인
로드맵 받는 것들이 앞으로 나오면서
전체적으로 관심이 어 하드웨어 관련한
종목들에서 좀 넓어질 수 있겠다 그런
생각을 좀 해 봤는데 맞나요? 저는
그렇게 생각했습니다. 왜냐면 사실 뭐
기업의 비즈니스 모델들이 바뀌는 거는
항상 뭐 그 기업단의 이슈긴 하지만
결국 그 향방이 투자로 어떻게 이어질
것인가를 주목해서 봤을 때 일차
우상이 판단했던 거는 다시 돈 버는
쪽으로 좀 더 집중을 해야 되나? 그
미인 대회에서도 이제 돈 버는 쪽으로
좀 더 [목을 가다듬음] 그
세그먼트를 봐야 되나라는 그래서
근본적인 질문이 좀 변화된 계기가
아니었나 요멘타 이슈가 그렇게 생각을
해봤습니다. 네. 이게 마켓 브로드
엮겨서 어 시장이 조금 더 과민한
반응을 하루짜리로는 했을 수도 있는데
어떻게 보여지는지에 대해서 저희가
계속 뉴스를 팔로잉하면서 포트폴리오
변화가 필요한지도 함께 보도록
하겠습니다. 오늘도 명료하게 요약해
주셔서 감사합니다. 가상자산으로
넘어가 보겠습니다. 준혁주임님
가상자산 지지부진한데 어제는 또 어떤
뉴스들이 있었는지 궁금합니다. 네.
사실 말씀드리겠습니다. 지지부진한
흐름 속에서 어제는 가격 흐름
괜찮았습니다. 어제 케비너시의 연설이
좀 주요에 따라 보면 될 거
같은데요. K비너시뿐만 아니라 22에
있는 그 유럽 쪽 그 중앙 은행에서
금리를 결정하는 인원들이 어
인플레이션 완화 인플레이션 압력이 좀
완화가 됐다. 그리고 케빈 어시도 어
인플레이션 위험은 조금 어 내려왔다.
그리고 어 기대 인플레이션도 좀 4주
연속 하락하고 있다라는 식의 발언을
해 주면서 어 결국해서 지금 이제
금리 인상에 대한 거에서 조금
멀어지는 그런 추세를 보여 주니까
다시 한번 비통 가격이 상승했다.
그리고 이제 금리 민 민감하게
반응하는 성상주의 흐름과도 같이
보여주기 때문에 지금 가격이
단기적으로 좀 반응해줬다라고 보시면
될 거 같 같습니다. 네. 오른쪽에
비트 장기 차트 보시면 한 6만 불
정도 지금 다시 회복한 상태를 보실
수 있을 것 같고요. 6,불 정도가
200주 이평선이거든요. 근데 제가
지난번에 한번 항상 사이클 사이클에서
200주 이평선을 조금 하회했다가
거기 바닥을 그 구간을 바닥을 잡고
다시 한번 상승한다는 말씀드린 적이
있는데 어 그 구간이 62,000불
정도가 될 거 같다라고 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 비트코인 프레드
인덱스 보시면 극단적 공포 구간은
11 정도 기록하고 있고요. 어,
현물 ETF 순위순 유출은 지금 요거
오른쪽 부분 보시면 다 빨간색밖에
없을 정도로 어, 유출이 계속해서
지속되고 있습니다. 그래서 한 7주
정도 연속 어, 계속 현물 ETF 순
순유출에서 순 유출로 어 기록하고
있다라고 하는데 6월 30일
기준으로는 222밀리언 정도가 유출이
됐다 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고요.
어제 제가 간단하게 말씀드리고 넘어간
내용이 있는데 어, 주요 쪽 보시면
서클의 시대는 이제 끝인가 하고 제가
제목을 지어 놨습니다. 어 6월
30일 한국시간으로 7월 1일 날
오픈 스탠더드라는 컨소 시험이 있는데
140개 140개 기업이 어 참여를
하고요. 어 달러 연동 스테이블
코인인 US 오픈 USD 그러니까
5USD라는 것을 공개를 했습니다.
실제로 지금 상용화가 되고 있는 것은
아니고 이런 걸 하겠다라는
컨소시엄식의 발표가 어에 좀 더
가까웠다라고 보시면 될 거 같고
코인베이스 비자 마스터카드 플랭로
구글 등이 참여를 하고 국내 기업에는
어 삼성전자 현대차 카카오도 포함이
돼 있었습니다. 어, 코인베이스를
저희가 좀 주목해서 보면 될 거
같은데 코인베이스는 USC에 그니까
서클의 비즈니스 모델에 참여를 하게
되면서 거기에 있는 수수료를 그
수익금을 어, 좀 약간 군배받는 그런
구조를 계속해서 지금까지 해 왔었는데
코인베이스가 다른 스테이블 코인에
지금 참여를 하고 있다. 약간 이런
식의 뉴스가 나오게 되면서 포인
베이스가 물론 양다리를 걸쳐 놓은 걸
수도 있겠지만 어 이거를 한쪽을 어
다른 한쪽에도 같이 배팅 했다는 걸
봤을 때 서클의 어 밸루에이션 조금
프리미엄이 깎이는 거 아닌가 이런
우료가 어 굉장히 강기 때문에 어제
주가가 한 16% 17% 빠졌다이
정도로 보시면 될 거 같고요. 그래서
오픈 스탠더드가 어떤 거를 소개하려고
하냐 오픈 USD라는 걸 소개하는
글이 있는데요. 스티블코인은 속도,
비용, 프로그래밍 가능성 때문에
빠르게 도입이 되고 있고 현재
거래량이 미국 잘동 자동 결제 어
자동 결제망인 ACH라는게 있다라고
합니다. 거기 네트워크에 육박한다.
하지만 기업들은 여전히 상당한 장벽에
직면해 있는데 대부분의 세이블
코인들은 발행 및 상환 수수료가
대규모 거래시 터문이 엄치이 비싸고
어 또한 기업들은 기초 준비금에서
발행하는 발생하는 수익들 국채에다가
투제 단기 국채 투자했을 때 나오는
수익들을 항상 배분받을 수 있는 것도
아니며 개발자들은 서드 파티 발행사의
로드맵에 로드맵이 자신들의 요구를
충족하지 못하더라도 대체할 방법이
거의 없다라고 합니다. 그래서 오픈는
어 세 가지 핵심 설계 원칙을
도입했다라고 하는데 빌 스케일이라고
하는게 아까 말씀드린 것처 발행 및
상환 수수료가 아예 없는 거고요.
그래서 기업들은 비용 부담이 없이
거래량에 대한 인위적 제한 없이 어
오픈를 발행하고 상환하는게 가능하다.
그리고 unarn by
default라고 두 번째 써 있는데
파트너들은 오픈의 운용 비용을
충당하기 위한 소액의 관리 수술을
제외한 준비금 수익 전액을
지급받는다라고 하고 어 세 번째로는
거 어 컬레이 해 가지고 다 같이
이제이 관리를 하게 된다라고 하는데
오픈 USD 독립법인은 오픈
스탠더드가 운영을 하게 되고 이자에는
오픈 USD 파트너들로 구성되어서
단일 주체가 아닌 공동의 이익을 위한
의사 결정이 이루어지도록 보장을
하겠다라고이 세 가지요 서클이하고
하고 있지 못하는 것들에 대한 세
가지를 우리가 핵심 설계 월칙으로
도입을 했다라는 콘솔 시험이 지금
이렇게 발표를 했다라고 보시면 될 거
같고요.이 오픈 USD 아까 그 오픈
스탠더드의 그 그 회장은 CEO는 어
스트라이프 결제 시스템 그리고
스테이블 코인 결제망에 어 수정이었던
스트라이프의 어 CEO였습니다.
CEO가 지금 이제 오픈스탠더드 오픈
USD를 만들었다라 보시면 될 거
같고요. 이게 실제로 상화가 되고
있는 건 아니기 때문에 이제서야 어
스티블코인 시장에 어 마켓어를 이제
조금조금씩 뺏어 와야 되는 그런
흐름으로 진행이 되고 있고 아직 어떤
네트워크 뭐 이더리움이든지
솔라나라든지 어느 체인에서 할지도
그렇게 확실하게 결정된 건 아닌 거
같습니다. 솔라나랑 처음에 하게
하겠다고 이렇게 발언 상태이지만
확실하게 정해진 건 없는 거 같고요.
왼쪽 밑에 있는 사진을 보시면 참여
기업이 한 140개 정도 됩니다.
국내 기업들도 있고 어 해외 기업들도
굉장히 많고요. 거의 코인 베이스가
있다라는 점이 굉장히 인상적이었다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그 현재 스티이블
코인 시장이 어떻게 돼 있냐를
오른쪽으로 보시면 될 거 같은데 한
311 빌리언 정도가 됩니다. 그래서
제가 로고는 어 가장 좀 중요한
플레이어들 두 개만 제가 넣어 놨는데
어 오른쪽 파란색 있는 부분이 테더
부분이고 테더가 한 60% 정도 지금
차지를 하고 있고요. USDC 저희가
알고 있는 서클이 한 24% 정도를
차지를 하고 있습니다. 결국 이제
오픈 5 USD가 나온다고 하더라도이
마켓에서 어느 정도 이제 시장 점유를
뺏어올 수 있는지가 앞으로
밸루에이션을 받을 수 있는 그런
가치일 텐데 그건 어느 정도 뺏어올
수 있을지는 사실 좀 약간 모음표가
붙어 붙어 있는 부분입니다.
어 밑에 좀 내려와서 제가 사진과
함께 간단하게 설명을 드리면 될 거
같습니다. 어 USDT 방금 말씀드린
1등의 수정의 반응을 제가 넣어
놨는데 어 환영한다. 우리 같이 한번
이거 한번 한번 해 보자. 약간 이런
식으로 반응을 했다라고 보시면 될 거
같고 USDC의 제레미 알리언은 조금
굉장하게 작문의 편지를 써 줬습니다.
그래서 어 왜이 컨소시엄이 조금
실패할 확률이 큰지 그리고 어떤
부분에서 어 우리가 지금까지 이런
비즈니스 모델 아까 말씀드린 어
oUSD가 아 이런 건 문제다 했던
부분들이 왜 문제가 아닌지를 설명해
준게 있었습니다. 그래서 아까 무료
발행하고 실행한 상환한다 이런 부분을
설명해 줬었는데 어 그런 부분들은
비용 문제 때문에 계속해서 상환이
들어오게 된다라고 하면 그게 감당이
안 된다라고 합니다. 그래서 그런
부분들은 반박을 정확하게 해 줬고요.
수익 전액 환원에 대해서는 수익을
파트너에게 다 퍼 주게 된다라고 하면
정작이 시스템을 안정적으로 유지하거나
보완적으로 조금 보안 보완적으로
발전시키는데 어 인프라가 부실해지는
그런 효과가 나온다라고 하거든요.
그래서 수익을 전에 다 이렇게 나눠
가지는 컨소시엄의 형태는 어 굉장히
단점이 있을 수가 있고 어 좀
제한적인 부분이 있다라고 말 해 주는
거고 어 세 번째로는 공동 거버넌스
어 이거는 약간 조금 비유적인 표현일
수도 있는데 배가 아 그니까 사공이
너무 많은 배가 산으로 간다 이런
말이 있잖아요. 그래서 물론 그
140개 기업들이 다 한 한 마디씩
하면서 의글번 하나씩 가지는 거는
아니지만 결국에 이런 시도가 여러 번
있었습니다. 한 30개 기업 정도가
모여서 우리 스테이블코인 한번 만들어
보자. 이런 프로젝트들이 여러 번
있었는데 그런 것들이 실패로
돌아갔었다. 어 그런 것들을 비유를
들어 주면서 어 그렇게 공동적으로
거버넌스를 참여하는 것도 약간
제한적이고 한계가 있을 수 있다라고
발언을 해 줬습니다. 어 그중에서도
거기 제가 어제 한번 말씀드린 적이
있었던 내용인데 여기 노란 색자가
하이라이트 해 놓은 부분 보시면
네트워크 이펙트라고 써 있습니다.
결국에 이미 선점해 놔서 그 네트워크
효과를 그리고 그 여기 약간
커뮤니티를 형성해 놓은게 어 약간
시장에서 압도적으로 유리할 수밖에
없다라는 부분인데 어 예를 들어서
저희가 지금 원화를 쓰고 있는데
갑자기 우리는 원화 말고 뭐
오후원화를 써라. 5원를 써라라고
하면 어 뭐 나이 드신 분들이나 이런
같은 그 그런 분들 같은 경우에는
굉장히 거부감을 가질 확률이 높다라고
전 지금 그냥 원하러 놨을 때도
있다고 생각하거든요. 어 그것도 사실
이제 USDC 스테이블 코인도 거의
비슷하다고 생각을 합니다. 그게
기업체 입장에서는 좋을 수가 있지만
기업체 입장에서는 우리 수익을 나눠
가진대 하고 굉장히 좋은 부분으로
작용을 할 수가 있지만 결국에 어
실제 사용하는 사람들 입장에서 그
수입금을 나눠 가지는게 아니기 때문에
실제 사용처에서는 어 그게 뭔데가 될
수 있다라고 생각을 하거든요. 그래서
그런 네트워크 이펙트를 생각해 봤을
때는 스테이블 코인이 이미 아까
말씀드린 그 어 점 마케시어가 크게
지각 변동이 있을 수 없을 수가 있을
것 같다. 그리고 지각 변동이 있다고
하더라도 스테이블코인 시장이 커짐에
따라서 어 코인 그 서클이 계속해서
벌어들 수익은 점점 커질 수 있다라는
점을 저희가 인지하면서 가면 될 거
같습니다. 그리고 아까 제가 말씀드린
네트워크 네트워크가 확실히 정해진 거
아닌 거 같다라고 말씀드린 부분이
가장 밑에 있는 사실 두 가지인데요.
어 솔라나가 처음에 이제 어 같이
하겠다. 오픈 USD랑 같이
하겠다라고 어 이렇게 진행이 됐는데
제가 지난번에 한번 말씀드린게
이더리움이 승자가 될 수밖에 없는
이유가 어 이더리움 위에서 올라가
있는 체인의 가치가 훨씬 크기 때문에
보완적인 가치나 보완적인 관점에
생각해 봤을 때도 이더리움 위에서
하는게 안전할 수밖에 없다라고 설명을
드린 적이 한번 있습니다. 그래서
오른쪽에 있는 체인별 그 아까
스테이블 코인 311빌리언 중에서
이더리움이 지금 스테이블 코인으로
차지하고 있는 비중이 50% 정도
가까이 되거든요. 그리고 2등이 그럼
솔라냐? 솔라나 2등이 아닙니다.
솔라나는 한 자리 수 4.8%이고요.
트론이라는 체인 29% 정도 차지하고
있습니다. 그러니까 솔라나를 선택해서
솔라나 안으로 간다라고 하는 거는 그
더 거대한 기업들이 지금 마켓 시어를
뺏어오겠다라고 하는 어 그 의지
속에서 이더리움도 아니고 솔라를
선택하는 거는 좀 위험한 선택일 수
있다라는 점을 간단하게 설명드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다. 그냥 큰 데서
하는게 무조건 유리하다 이렇게
생각하시면 되는게 맞는 것 같습니다.
그래서 랩업을 들이면 결국에 지금
컨소시엄이 여러 가지가 여러 기업들이
참여해서이 스테이블 코인 시장을 한번
뺏어 보겠다라는 어 의미로 한번
출범을 했다라고 보여지는데 어 그
출범의 의미가 실제로이 스테이블 코인
시장을 뺏어오기 위함이 아니라 그
걔네가 하고자 하는 프로젝트 자체에
그 의가 어 양다리를 걸치기 좋은
프로젝트라고 생각합니다. 그래서 이거
여기 나와 있는 준비금 수익 같은
것도 다 나눠 준다. 이런 의에서
그냥 한번 어 코인베이스도 그렇고 뭐
우리나라의 국내 기업들도 그렇고 그게
실제로 될 거다라고 생각해서라기보다는
실제이 컨소시엄이 하고자 하는 의를
어 여러 가지 방면에서 검토해 봤을
때 투자해 볼 만하다 생각해서이
컨소시엄이 출범을 했고 스테코인이
나왔다라고이 정도로 저는 지금 현재
단편적으로 좀 보여지거든요. 그래서
실제 서클의 어 그 밸류이지 자체가
아니면 큰 그림 자체가 그렇게
훼손되진 않았다. 그리고 애초에 어
스테이블코인 시장이 전체적으로 한
2틀년 달러 정도까지 커진다고
생각했을 때 그렇게 그림 자체가
훼손된 거는 아닌 거 같다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다.요 며칠 사이는 우리 준역
주임이 가상자산 자체의 가격
분석보다는 가상자산을 둘러싸고 있는
기업들이 어떤 위기에 직면하고 어떻게
이합 집산하고 이런 제도와 관련된
것들이 어떻게 변화하고 이런 것들
계속 설명해 주시는 거 같아요. 아,
큰 틀에서이 산업을 이해하는데 도움이
많이 되는 거 같습니다. 계속 공부해
보도록 하겠습니다. 1부 여기까지
하도록 하겠습니다. 일부 함께 해
주신 채మి물 여러분 감사드리고요.
잠시 후 보다 자세한 내용들로
2부에서 뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
>> [음악]
[음악]
>> 안녕하십니까 최밀턴 여러분. 행복한
투자정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝 브리프
7월 2일 목요일 2부 시간인데요.
지금 점님께서 외부 줌 세미나
중이셔서 제가 잠시 앞쪽에 진행을 좀
하다가 나오시면 교체하도록
하겠습니다. 어 조금 꿀꿀한 미국
시장 브리핑을 좀 받았는데 이게
반도체 중심으로 투자가 돼 있다
보니까 조금 꿀꿀한 거지 뭐 시장이
무너졌다적인 매크로가 흐러졌다 그런
건 아니고요. 어떤 디테일이 있는지
우리 부사장님께 들어보겠습니다.
>> 예.
>> 일단 지수를 보시면은 그냥 약법
정도로 다우나 SMP
2천 이렇게 끝났잖아요. 근데 필반
지수가 6% 하락 그랬습니다.
그래서 어제 이제 101. 뭐 1
이렇게 말씀을 드렸는데 지금
88.5로
꽤 한 뭐 100에서 보면은 단순
수치로 12% 빠진 거라 돼
있잖아요. 그래서 6% 빠졌는데 왜
12%
빠진 것처럼 보이냐? 뭐 이렇게
[목을 가다듬음]
보일 수 있는데 기준점이 다르니까
100에서 200 갔다가 6% 빠지면
10이 빠지는 거잖아요. 그래서 결국
이제 88% 된 건데 어쨌든 그거는
그렇고요. 반도체가
상당히 타격을 받았던 하루고 또
그러면서 어 전반적인 로테이션 어제
뭐 대표님하고도 잠깐 얘기했지만
브로드닝이 일어나 섹터 확산이
일어났던 어 하루였던 거 같습니다.
매크로 쪽 보면은 어 금리 뭐
10년물 기준으로 1.42표은
4.48%고 48%고 유가도 빠지고
크게 뭐 어 변화가 없었는데
그리고
또 S ISM 제조 PMI도
그 어 시장 컨센보다는 좀 낮았지만
그래도 뭐 양호하게 나왔고 근데
하나의 뉴스가 전반적으로 이제 반도체
어 센티멘트를 약화시키는 어 그런 그
작용을 했습니다. 유리프로가
얘기했듯이 이제 메타 관련됐었데 어
일단 좀 이따 보기로 하고 일단 그
6월 ISM 제조 PMI부터 보면은
실제로 53.3이 나와서 어 컨센서스
53.9
이전 54 대비해서 좀 낮았습니다.
그리고 어 세부 내용을 보면은 신규
주문이나 생산, 공급자 배송 이런
것들이 좀 어 감소를 했고요.
그리고 아 고용 지표가 오늘 나올
텐데 아 고용은 오늘 아 고용은 그
ISM 제조업 PMI 내에서는 어
5월이 48.6에서 49.7로 7로
좀 증가를 했고요. 물가는 그 5월이
82.1에서 1에서
6월이 73으로 확 낮아졌습니다.
유가 자체가 좀 낮아지니까 물가 쪽에
영향을 준 거 같고요.
제조업 중에서 가장 큰 여섯 개 제조
가운데 석탄하고 석유 이쪽만
제외하고는 모두 확장세를 기록했다고
ISM에서 얘기하고 있고요. 확장
강도로 보면은 컴퓨터 및 전자 제품
그리고 기계 운송 장비 화학 제품
식품 음료 담배요 순위라고 했
합니다. 그래서
IT 쪽 기계 쪽 운송 장비 쪽 어
좋은 종부고요.
설문 응답은 좀 결이 다른 것들도
있는데
참고해서 보시면은 화학 제품
쪽에서는이란 분쟁이 모든 원자 가격에
영향을 미치면서
>> 접착처럼 어 원제료 구성해서 석유
비중이 높은 품목들의 영향이 컸다고
얘기를 했고 컴퓨터 및 전자 제품은
중동 분쟁이 지속되면서 어 케펙스에
대해 보다 보수적인 접근을 하고 있고
다만 소모품과 서비스 구매가 증가하고
있다라고
얘기를 하고 습니다. 전기 장비 가전
부품 쪽에서는 소매 전자 제품 판매는
어느 정도 안정된 것으로 판단하고
있다고 코멘트했고요.
식품 음료 담배 쪽에서는 주요 원재료
비용은 중동 분쟁과 관세 불확실성
때문에 여전히 높은 수준이고 공급처를
다변화하고 계약 구조를 조정해서 비용
안정성과 운영 유연성을 동시에
확보하려고 노력 중.
그리고 기계는 방위산업과 반도체
제조를 지원하는 기계 수요가 매우
강하다라고 했는데 아 최근에 반도체
장비 쪽에 주가 모멘텀이 강한
부분하고
일맥 상통하는 거 같습니다. 기타
제조는 지정학적 불확실성 속에서도
핵심 사업은 견조하다고 얘기를
했고요.
어 석유 석탄 제품은 일한 전쟁이
끝날 가능성이 높아지면서 최근 육가
상승이 정상화될 가능성으로 예상된다.
운송 장비는 새로운 관세가 어
수익성과 수요를 계속 훼손하고 있고
세금 부담을 감당하기 위해 가격을
올릴 수밖에 없다. 그래서 대체로 어
업태별로 좀 다르긴 하지만 어 평양
코멘트를 했다고 생각을 하고 있고요.
기계 쪽에서 반도체 제조 관련된 기계
수요가 매우 강하다는 점. 그리고 어
석탄 석유 제품 쪽에서 유가 상승이
정성화될 것으로 예상된다는 점. 어,
이런 부분들은 긍정적인 코멘트로
해석이 됐습니다.
어, 메타의 클라우드 사업 진출이
어제 반도체 전반적인 센티먼트를
회전시켰는데
결과적으로 보면은 좀 저는 과잉
반응이었다고 생각을 하고 있고요.
일단 메타
그 블룸버그 뉴스 자체를 보면은
메타가 AI 컴퓨팅 자원을 외부에
판매하는 클라우드 인프라 사업을 계획
중이다. 딱 이렇게 헤드라인만 읽어
보면은 어 메타가 컴퓨팅 자원이 남기
때문에 외부에 판매하고 이제 더 이상
케펙스에 대한 추가 수요가 없나 뭐
이런 식으로 좀 해석을 할 수가
있잖아요. 네. 그
메타의 어떤이 이런 비즈니스 전략은
어쨌든 그 남는 어 잉여 컴퓨팅
자원으로 매출을 창출하고 또 AI
인트라 투자를 회수하는데 도움이 될
수 있을 거라고 일단 시장에서 어
메타에 대해서는 긍정적인 어 해석을
하면서 메타 주가가 어제 어 급등을
했고요. 어, 내부 사정을 보면은
메타가 구축하고 있는 자체 모델이
라마라고 하는 모델인데이 모델이 어,
경쟁사들에 비해서 좀 경쟁력이
떨어지면서 얼마 전까지도 그
재미나이의
경쟁사 구글의 재미나이 어, 모델을
이용한 것으로 알려졌습니다.
그리고이
그 전반적인 메타에 대한 해석 자체는
어 CEO가 어 초고도 AI 개발을
공원하고 인재 영입도 공격적으로 하고
어 인프라 확대도 했지만 어 제대로
된 성과를 내지 못하고 있었다는 어
평가가 있고요. 그런데 그 메타가
그 구글에 제미나이를
쓰고 있었는데 구글이 메타한테
재미나의 사용량을 어 제한을
했었고요.이 조치로 그 메타의 A
프로젝트가 프로젝트 일부가 차질이
발생했었고 어 메타는 구글 모델에
대한 수요가 높았기 때문에 타격을
입은 것으로 알려졌다. 그래서 이게
파이낸셜 타임즈인데 아 이걸 굳이
이제 길게 말씀드리는 이유는
내부적으로 자체 모델 자이 어 경쟁사
대비 어 좀 경쟁 우위 차원에서 좀
어 좀 낮았다 부족했다 요걸 좀
말씀을 드리고 싶고요. 그리고
그 메타가 어 그 다른 이제
하이퍼스케일러들은 클라우드 외우
판매가 있었던 반면에 어 메타는 외부
판매가 없었던 어 상황에서 어 잉여가
좀 있었을 있었을 수도 있겠다.
그런데 어 그 잉여를 어 내부적으로
활용하기보다는
외부적으로 활용하는게 더
좋을 수자가 있겠다라는 이런
비즈니스적인 어 판단이 있었을 것
같고 그와는 별대로 별도로 어
내부적인 모델 자체는 다른 경쟁사업도
좀 떨어져 있었다. 이런 배경을 좀
이해하는게 좋을 거 같고. 어 이렇게
되면 이제 메타가 클라우드 시장에서
어 AWS 그 애저 그리고 구글 같은
선도 업체들하고 새로운 경쟁 구도를
형성할 가능성이 어 높은데 일부에서는
어 이런
메타의 계획을 두고 메타가 AI
인프라를 과도하게 구축한 것이
아니냐는 어 우려가 제기되면서 어제
그 반도체 쪽 그러깐 인프라 쪽에 그
어 투매가 나왔던 걸로 어 파악이
되고 있고 어 이제 메타가 예상보다
많은 GPU하고 데이터 센터를
확보했고 어 이제 남은 자원을 외부에
판매하려 한다면 향후 추가적인 AI
인프라 투자가 줄어드는 것 아니냐는
해석이 있을 수가 있습니다. 그런데
어이 부분에 대해서 그 누구도 이제
확답을 할 수가 없는 부분이지만 어
이따 보시겠지만 어 매월 그
AI 케펙스 하이퍼스케일러들의 AI
케펙스를 추적하고 있는 JP모건에
그 따르면은 어 전반적으로 그
하이퍼스케일러들의 AI케스는
지난 4월에 비해서도 그 6월 말기
기준으로 어 늘어난 것으로 어 보이고
있기 때문에 총량 자체에 AI 인프라
투자가 어 메타 때문에 줄어든다
이렇게 보기는 좀 어려울 거 같고요.
이번에 이제 메타에 클라우드 사업
진출은 새로운 소식은 아닌데 아 지난
25년 3분기 어닝스콜에서 밝힌 바에
따르면 외부에서 남는 그 컴 컴퓨팅
용량을 쓸 수 있는지 문의가 오고
있고 만약 오버빌드 상태 뭐 과잉
상태가 되면 외부 판매를 옵션으로
가질 수 있다고 어 언급한 바가
있습니다. 그래서 어이 부분이 약간
그 조직도 갖추고 실제로 어떻게
판매할 것인지에 대한 방법론도
갖췄다는 측면에서 어 좀 현실화되는
어 그런 느낌이 있고요. 그래서
2번의 신설한 조직은 메타 컴피트라는
조직인데 여기에서 AI 인프라
구축하고 운영을 위한 인력 구성이
되고 어 방식은 개발자가 메타
인프라에 탑재한 AI 모델에 접근해서
구동에 필요한 컴퓨팅 파워에
비용을내는 방식이 있을 수가 있고 어
또 하나는 제 3자에게 용량을
판매하는 것으로 어 네오클라우드처럼
컴퓨팅 용량 자체를 를 판매하는
방식인데이 방식이 네오클라우드 업체
그 아이덴이나 네비우스나 코위브가
하는 방식이거든요. 예. 완전히
비즈니스 구조가 겹치기 때문에 그
비즈니스의 경쟁자 강력한 경쟁자가
한나가 들어왔다는 것만으로도 어 그
기존 업체들한테는 좀 위협이 될 수
있을 만한 아 상항으로 해석이 돼서
어제 네오클라우드 업체들의 주가가
급락을 했었고요. 어, 지금까지
대략적으로 이제 배경 설명하고 그
팩트 체크를 좀 해 봤는데 여기에서
어떤 시사점이라고 좀 본다면은
메타트는 분명히 밑에 보시면은 그
이익률 관련해서 보시면은 이익률이
계속해서 좀 정치 상태 있고 이번에
그 2분기에 발표된 이익률 자체가
시장에서 35.7%로 7%로 앞자리가
좀 바뀌는 어 그런 수준으로 나와
있기 때문에 메타 내부적으로도 상당히
고민이 있었을 거라고 생각을 하고
있고요. 밑에
케팩스 보면은 어 33.6빌리언으로
작년 그 1분기에 작년 2분기에
비해서 거의 어 두 배가 늘어나는
거거든요. 그리고 그다음 분기에도 어
39.6빌리언으로 6빌리언으로
돼 가지고 케펙스는 계속해서
늘어나는데 이익률
그 하락에 대한 아 내부적인 고민이
상당히 했을 것 같습니다. 일단
시장에서는 좀 이렇게 보고 어 있는
상황에서 어 지금 메타가 그
계획하고 있는 어 클라우드 외브
판매, 컴퓨팅 판매 이런 부분들이
아주 새로운 것은 아닌데 아 최근에
스페이스 X 같은 경우가 엔트로픽의
월 12.5억 불을 받고 그리고 어
구글에 한 9.2억 2억부를 받고
이런 컴퓨팅
파워를 제공하는 계약을 맺은 바가
있거든요. 그리고 그래서 메타도 어
남는 잉여 자원을 컴퓨팅 자원을 어
웹로 이렇게 돈을 받고 어 판매하는
이런 비즈니스의 설례를 어 따르기로
한 거 아닌가라는
어 판단이 가능하고요. 어 그 이외
그 중요한게 어 인프라 쪽에서 투자
관점에서의 어 케팩스인데 일단 그
메타가 그 지난 1분기 어닝 스콜이
4월 29일 날 열렸는데 여기에서 어
케펙스 가이던스를 올해
125빌리언에서
145빌리언으로
어 상향 조정했었습니다. 그러면서 한
말이 어깨 전반에 보이는 모든 신호가
투자에 확신을 주고 있다. 그러고
언급을 하면서 어이 그 이때까지
어쨌든 어 투자 그 케펙스 투자에
대한음
그 어떤 어 믿음은 어 계속 이어졌던
걸로 보이고 있고 또 이때 시점에서
어 기존의 케펙스 투자를 더 늘리기로
한 것도 역시
어 그 투자에 대한 의지를 어 확인을
할 수 있는 부분이라고 볼 수
있고요.
어, 다만 이제 자체 개발한 AI
모델의 효율이 떨어진다는 점. 그리고
케펙스 투자 대비 이익률이 하락하고
있다는 점을 감시 어 이러한 그
비즈니스 구조에 약간 어 변화를 주는
어 전략적 선택이 있었을 거라고 어
생각을 합니다. 따라서
이번 조치가 그 메타한테는이 3자
판매를 통한 어 비즈니스의 어떤 어
좀 변화를 통해서 어 매출이나
이익이나 이익률 개선에 어느 정도
도움이 될지는 좀 가봐야 될 텐데
아무것도 하지 않는 거보다는 어 훨씬
나은 결정이라고 생각을 하고 있고요.
예를든 네러티브로 인해서 어쨌든 어
주가는 한번 반응을 했고 [콧방귀]
어 이번에 7월 29일로 예정되 있는
실적 발표에서이 부분에 대한 디테일이
있을 걸로 어 생각을 하고 있고요.
그때까지 약간 케픽스를 둘러싼 이슈로
인해서 반도체를 비롯한 인프라
관련주들의 변동성은 좀 있을 것
같습니다. 이게 뭐 많이 틀리니 어
또는 해석 자체가 어떻게 되니에
따라서 왔다 갔다 할 수는 있을 것
같은데이 뉴스 하나만 가지고 그
AI의 방향성 그 인프라의 방향성이
어 끝났다 또는 픽아웃했다라고 보기는
좀 어 어렵다고 판단을 하고
있습니다. 그래서이 메타 같은 경우
지금 어 PR 기준으로 어제 좀
올라서 어 14배 수준에서 15배
수준으로 어 PR이 많이 내려왔고요.
현재 그 최근 1년간을 보면 한
22배까지 갔다가 어 주가 하락으로
인해서 어 PR이 많이 내려온
상황이고
그 포드 EPS 같은 경우는 이번에
나와 봐야 되겠지만
약간 그 시장에서의
눈높이는
이번에 발표로 인해서 아 조금
높아지지 않을까라는 생각이 듭니다.
어 밑에 그래서 이제 하이퍼스케일러들
케펙스의 총량 자체가 어떻게 변하고
있나 계속해서 예민하게 어 추적을
하고 있는데 어 JP모가의 가이투서
마켓에서 어 매월 나오는
팩스 투자 규모를 좀 업데이트를 해해
드리면은 4월 [콧방귀] 말 추정했을
때 26년팩스가
723빌년
27년이 85빌년 그리고 28년에
추장이 됐었는데 이때가 바로 그
1분기 실적 발표 어 끝나고 어 최신
업데이트된 어 버전이 일했었는데
지금 한 두 달 정도 어 지난
상황에서 보면은 26년이음
758빌리언 그리고 27년이
925빌리언
30 28년이 어 986빌리언으로
어 대체로 어 계속해서 추정치는
우상향하는 걸로 로 돼 있고요. 뭐
지난번에도 말씀드렸다시 어
말씀하셨다시피
어 반도체 가격 또는 메모리 가격
부채 저장 장치 가격 이런 것들에
의한 어 상향 조정이이 부분에는 어
상당히 반영되 있지 않을까 싶습니다.
>> 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 우선
쪽 얘기를 듣고 저는 어 일부 때
우리 유리프로가 해 주신 얘기 듣고
이러 이렇게 생각이 되는데라고 말했던
것과 제 마음이 또 판랑이로
바뀌었어요.
>> 아 어떻게 바뀌니까? 아, 이게
적절한 비유인지 모르겠는데 말씀을 쭉
듣고 보니까 어떤 생각이 들었냐면
음,
>> 만약에 어떤 그 식당 비즈니스로
생각을 해 볼 때
>> 네.
>> 어, 어떤 대기업들이 이제 큰 메인
스트릿에 큰 가게 차려 놓고 비즈니스
식당을 하고 있고 골목 사건 상권에
또 이렇게 자잘자잘한 곧 사이즈에
맞게 장사를 잘하고 있는 기업들이
있었는데 큰 식당이 어, 장사가 잘
안 되고 손님이 잘 안 되니까
>> 예. 그 메인스트레에 있는 가게를 한
절반으로 줄이고 내가 골목상권으로
들어가서 내이 브랜드를 가지고
비즈니스를 하겠다라고 이제 뛰어든
거예요. 그러면 어이 식재료를
납품하는 입장에서는
>> 골목상권은 골목상권대로 내 식재료를
갖다 쓰고
>> 그리고 큰 그 어 메인스트레에 있는
큰 식당들은 프랜차이즈들은
내 식재료를 가져다가 이제 손님들에게
다 음식을 해서 외기고 그래야지 좋은
거긴 한데
>> 음
>> 손님이 좀 안 들더라도 식제료는
어차피
>> 어 갖고 갔다가 폐기돼도 난 일단
팔았으니까
>> 그래야 전체적으로 매일이 좀 커지는
건데 [목을 가다듬음]
>> 어 이게 이제 메인 스트릿을
가을 좀 줄이고 볼목상권으로 오면
내가 팔 수 있는 식재료의 양은
줄어드는 거 아닌가라는 걱정을
>> 해볼 수도 있겠다. 이게 이제
메모리죠.이 비즈니스로 오면
>> 그래서
>> 어 메모리의 수요가 줄어드는 것이라고
하는 직접적인 타격은 아니겠구나라고
일부 마칠 때까지 생각했는데
>> 부사장님 설명을 들으니까 그럴 수도
있겠구나를 좀 바뀌었어요.
>> 음. 음.
[콧방귀] 이게
아 그 관건은 두가 두 가지인 거
같은데
>> 어이
메타의 자체적인
그런 그 비즈니스의 결정 자체가
지금 아 내부적으로 그 AI 케펙스를
아 AI 모델을 구축해서 내부
효율화를 지금까지 해 왔잖아요.
애왔고 그런 부분들을
어떻게 그런 부분들이에 얼마나 어
개선이 되는지 더 개선할 여지가
있는지
>> 더 개선할 여지가 있다면 아 뭐 최신
GPU라든지
최신 메모리라든지 이런 부분들을 더
끌어다 쓸 수 있겠죠. 그리고 그
이전에 구축해 놨던 월단 그 컴퓨팅
자원 이런 자원들은
>> 그 사실 그 지금 현재 어 학습
모델을 구축하기는 좀 어려운
모델이잖아요. 그렇지만 출론 수요가
계속 늘어나니까 분명히 외부 수요가
있을 거고
>> 그래서 비즈니스 어 차원에서
내부 수요 내부 수요를 조금 더
확장하기 위해서 인프라를 가져다 쓰는
거하고 또 그 전반적으로 어 사업
전체에 매출하고 이익 이익률을
끌어올리기 위해서 어 외부 판매를
본격화하는 거하고이 이 어 둘 간의
어떤 균형을 잡아야 될 텐데요 부분에
대한 좀 그 디테일이 좀 나와야 될
것 같습니다. 그래서
>> 어 일단은 3분기 그 지난 1분기의
그 어닝콜에 비추어 보면 어 케펙스를
투자하더라도 여기에 [목을 가다듬음]
대한 어 믿음과 신념이 있다라고
얘기를 했었잖아요. 근데 어 두
가지로 봤을 때 그러니깐 어 우리는
지금까지 케팩스 해 왔고 좀 남아
그리고어요 정도로 우리는 어 그
케팩스는 어 유지할 거야 또는
여기에서 더 늘리지 않을 거야 이런
코멘트가 나오는 건지 아니면 어
비즈니스 자체를 판을 바꿔서 우리는
어 외부 판매에 더 신경을 써서 어
>> 좀
다른 비즈니스 모델로 가기 위해서
케스가 더 필요해. 이렇게 갈 건지
아, 요거는 조금 더 확인을 해봐야
될 것 같습니다.
>> 예. 어, 이렇게 분기 실적 보여
주신 거. 그리고 추정치 보면
매출액도 성장률이 낮아지고 있고
영업익률의 높이도 계속해서 낮아지고
있어서
>> 어, 이걸 어떻게든 좀 타기해야
된다. 내부 고민이 많을 것은 분명한
거 같습니다. 네.
>> 우리 문상훈님.
>> 네. 저희이 준비해 주신 부사장님
준비해 주신 자료 어떤 생각이 좀
드셨습니까?
>> 예. 아까 논의 한 발을 이제
제사장님께서 이제 같이 요약을 해
주세요. 네.
>> 어 같은 맥락으로 생각을 하고
있고요.
>> 일단은 훈련 지금 차재드 모델을 이제
훈련을 완료한 걸로 알고 있어요.
그래서메타가
>> 예.
몇 달 후면은 런칭이 될 거 같은데
그 전까지 지금
>> 그 최선단 케파가 놀고 있어야 되는
상황이거든요.
>> 그런 것들을 지금 외부 판매하는
용도로 쓰고 있는 거 같아요.
>> 음. 그렇다고 지금 당장 출론 수요가
메타가 많은게 아니잖아요. 요거는
이제 스펙스 그록도 마찬가지예요.
똑같은 스킴으로 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 그래서 이걸 갖다가 뭐
케팩스가 주에만 하는 건 아직은
판단하기 시계 상조일 것 같습니다.
>> 아주 명료하게 [웃음]
어 그냥 지금 전체적으로 투자의
사이클이 꺾인다거나 이런 걱정은 아직
좀 많이 이르다.
>> 예. 조금 더 시간을 반영할 거
같아요.
>> 뭐 메타 자체로는 어저께 주가가 8%
이상 오른 게
>> 어 뭐 기업으로 치자면 가동률이 저
밑에 있다가 좀 높아질 수 있겠다는
기대가 있으니까 단기 급등은 그럴 수
있겠습니다. 그동안 주가도 워낙
부진했고
>> 주가 반응을 보면서 사실
기존에 클라우드 비즈니스의 절대
강좌들은 AWS나 마이크로소프트나
어 구글이잖아요. 어 얘네가 한
60% 정도 차지하는데 메타가이
사업을 본격화한다.
클라우드 쪽에서 비즈니스가 아
플레이어가 하나 아 들어온다. 센
애가 들어온다.라는
어떤 그 시장의 인식이 확산됐다면 음
>> 어 기존에
그 잘 하고 있던 어과 체제 클라우드
시장에서 하나가 더 들어오니까 얘네도
주가의 타격을 받았어야 할 거
같거든요.음. 음.
>> 근데 뭐 기존에 옳은게 없다거나
주가가 뭐 이미 빠져 있다거나 아
이런 이유로 인해서 얘네들은 그냥
그대로 있었고 또 네오클라우드
업체들한테도 이제 직접적인 경쟁
관계가 되기 때문에 어 걔네들은 이제
주가가 이미 좀 올라 있었고 어 좀
체력적으로 약한 애들이니까 걔네만
타격을 받았는지
요런 부분들도 조금음
>> 생각해야 봐야 될 부분이 아닌가?
그 만약에 이게 진짜 크리티컬
했더라면은 저는 어 구글이나
마이크로소프트나
어 그 아마존도 같이 빠어야 된다고
생각을 하고 있거든요.
>> 어 그렇게 되지 않은 거는 어 시장의
클라우드 CEO가 이미 어 공급을
초과하고 있다는 함의를 주고 있지
않은가라고 생각을 하고 있고 어
주가가 이미 많이 빠져 있었기 때문에
빠질 룸 자체가 없었다. 그리고 또
어 밸루에이션 멀티플 자체가 많이
내려와 있다. 어 요런 부분도 어
가만된게 아닌지 싶고요. 그리고 별로
상관없는 애들 그 소프트웨어들 애들도
어 어제 많이 오른 거를 봐서는 그냥
수급의 이동 뭐 심리의 이동 뭐
섹터의 확산 뭐 솔림의 어 완화 뭐
요런 정도 그 과열을 조금 냉각시키는
어 그런 정도가 아니었나 싶습니다.음
음. 알겠습니다.
미국 시장 어떻게 계속 변화하는지
하루짜리만 보면 또 저희가 신증을
확정하기가 좀 어려우니까 계속해서
우리가 집요하게 아주 우리 최보
사장님이 트래킹 해 주실 거라 믿고
오늘은 저기까지 듣고 넘어가
보겠습니다. 국내 시장으로 [콧방귀]
넘어가 보겠습니다. 한국 시장 어저께
어떻게 됐습니까? 회장님.
아, 네. 전유 시장
말씀드리겠습니다. 코스피 2% 하락
마감했고 코스닥 1.4% 오르면서
지수 차별화가 나타났고요. 수급적으로
봐 주시면 개인 투사자 1조 7,억대
현물 매수를 한 반면에 외국인
쪽에서상 1조 7,억 정도 매도세가
있었습니다. 어 외국인 선물에서는 또
1조 7천억 정도 매수하면서 선물에
대해서 좀 강한 매수세가 유입이
되기도 했고요. 투자별 매매 동향
보면 외국인이 DBI텍 삼성전기
리노궁업 한미 반도체 이오테크
HPSP 솔브레인 등의 반도체 소부장
중심으로 매수를 좀 강하게 했던 거
같고요. 그 외에 어 매도 쪽을 가서
보면 삼성전자, SK 스퀘어,
이수페터시스, 현대차, 에코프로,
후성 등을 매도했습니다. 기간
매수에는 SK스Q케어 주성 엔지니어링
이수 페타 효성 중공업 하나
에어로스페이스 삼성 전기 등을
매수했고요. 기간 매도에는 SK닉스
삼성전자 HPSP 한미 반도체
리동호업 등을 매도했습니다.
52주 신고가는 22개가 나왔는데요.
코스피에서 신세계 K시텍 금모 건설
신고가였고요. 금모 건설은 매일 뭐
상한가 가는 느낌이
>> 코스닥에서 PSK, 심텍, 유진테크,
테스, VM, 인바디, 인테플러스
등이 어 신고가 이름 올리면서
코스닥은 확실히 소부장들이 좀 눈에
띄게 많았던 거 같습니다.
뭐 종목 확산이라는 말이 잘 어울리는
한국 시장이었던 거 같고 어, 외국인
매도 보면은 어저께
이게 거래소 기준이죠, 과장님. 1조
7천억 정도데 매도 나온게 어 이제
1, 2조 나오면 그만 팔려고 하나
다 팔았나 이런 생각 들 정도로
그동안 매기가 굉장히 셌다가 좀
줄어들었는데 오늘도 어떻게 되나 좀
보고
>> 어 주변에 좀 이렇게 사람 그 업계
관계 지인들 말씀하시는 거 보면
상반기 중에 좀 클로징한 회지
펀드들도 제법 좀 있다 하고 성과를
>> 어 확정하는 그런 매매들이 많이
있었다고 하니까 칼렌더 이어가 가
사실은 영속하는 기업이라는 관점에서는
하나도 안해 보이지만 또 주가라고
하는 면에서 보면은 수급적으로 중요한
어떤 마디가 될 수도 있기 때문에 어
7월 달에 외국인 매도가 좀 줄어드나
하는 부분도 관심사인데 일단은 좀
줄어든 거 같긴 합니다. 매도는
매도지만 이런 부분 좀 보고 싶고요.
[콧방귀] 어, 그리고 어저께 쭉 장
마치고 보다 보니까 리노공업 같은
경우는 외국인이
100만 주 이상 사고 네. 어,
국내 기관이 100만 주 이상
매도해서 이게 장충에 한 건가 아니면
어저께 장 전이나 마감 후에 블록딜를
한 건가 하는 생각이 들 정도로
수량이 굉장히 많았어요. 그런
부분들은 좀 궁금했습니다. 아마
블록들이 있었다면 오늘은 전일자를
거래소에 들어가면 볼 수 있기 때문에
체크해 보도록 하겠습니다. 우리 쭉
어저께 7월 첫째 날을 한국 시장
대응하면서
>> 변화가 좀 왕의사님 느껴지셨습니까?
어땠습니까? 아, 네. 그 어제
시작부터 최근에 [콧방귀]
그 한 며칠 동안의 시장 흐름을
보면은 어, 삼성자 하이닉스가 조금씩
조종받다 보니까 다른 쪽으로 순환매가
좀 나왔었거든요.
>> 사실 오늘 이젠 그 새벽에 저희 어,
비장 종목들 빠진 거 보고 험이 좀
받았잖아요. 그래서 오늘도 어 일단
삼성자이닉스가 하락해서 뭐 출발할
거는 당연히 이제 하락해서 출발할 거
같은데 어 [목을 가다듬음] 전에 한
달 전의 상황을 놓고 보면은 한 5%
이상 삼성자이닉스가 이제 세게 밀릴
때는 다른 종목들이 엄청 세게
빠졌어요.
>> 음
>> 그랬잖아요.
>> 같이
>> 같이네 근데 최근에는 그 파락폭이
삼성자 하이닉스가 그렇게 크진
않았었거든요. 그러다 보니까 다른
쪽으로 수납매가 돌았었는데
>> 오늘은 어떻게 될까 이게 궁금합니다,
저도.
>> 음.
>> 그래서 이따가 시장을 보면서 그
부분을 좀 어 와치를 해야 되지
않을까라고 생각을 하고 있습니다.
>> 그리고 쭉 보니까 그 매수매도 종목들
이렇게 말씀해 주실 때 ETF 매매가
되게 많았는데
>> 네.
>> 어 보이긴 하지만 많이 없습니다.
이런 부분들은 또 어떻게 해석을 해야
되나 모르겠네.
우리 오과장님
ETF 매매가 주는
[웃음] 잘 모르겠습니다. 그냥 뭐
단순하게 생각해 보면
>> 전자닉스 투자자가 많은데
>> 음
>> 전자닉스의 주가가 좀
>> 단기적으로 좀 많이 빠졌다 보니
>> 네
>> 굳이 ETF 말고 ETF 판 다음에
전자닉스 개별주를 사자. 음. 그런
성격이 있지 않았을까 싶기.
>> 음.
>> 기초 재산으로 포함될 만한 시가 총액
상위 종목들 움직임이 둔해지니까
그냥 직접 개별 종목 매매로 좀
많아진 거 같다. [콧방귀]
대연성 있습니다. 그 정도 이해하고
넘어가 보겠습니다. 종목들 좀
볼까요?
>> 네. 네. 어제 반도체 섹터 보면
대형 반도체가 좋지 않았습니다.
삼성전자 5.8% 하락 마감했고
SK닉스도 3.4% 하락 마감하면서
최근에 대형 반도체 주가의 흐름이
다소 약해지고 있는 상황인 거
같고요. 아래 소부장 종목들은 뭐
여전히 비슷합니다. 뭐 급등하는 종목
있으면 또 금 좀 조정받는 종목들도
나오고 하는 혼조세가 이어지고
있는데요. 지난주에 많이 올랐었던 뭐
이오테크닉스 이런 종목도 약세
전환하기도 했었고 전일자에선 파크
시스템.
주성 엔지니어링이 뭐 특별한 이슈는
없었던 거 같은데 20% 급등 기록을
했습니다. 심택 한 6% 정도
올랐고요. 이수페타시스도
기판 업체 중에 가장 좀 부진하게
주가가 움직이고 있었던 회사인데 어제
한 13% 가량 급반에 성공을 하는
모습입니다.
IT 섹터는 전기가 1% 상승으로
마감을 했고요. LG 전자나 LG
이노택은 또 약세 흐름으로 마감을
했습니다. LG 이노텍의 주가가 원스
기준으로 40%가 빠져 있습니다.
지난 달에 굉장히 중순까지였나요?
되게 핫하게 올랐었는데
펀더멘탈 찾아가는 느낌이 좀 든다라는
생각이 듭니다. [웃음]
네. 예. 좀 과했지 않았나라고
저번에 말씀드렸는데 과했던게 맞는 거
같습니다.
>> 그때는 목소리 힘이 좀 없었어.
>> 제 생각과 다르게 너무 셌어.
>> 네. 그런 생각이 들었고요.
반면에 삼성전이 좀 탄탄하죠. 올해
이번 달 들어와서 아직 10% 플러스
수익은 기록 중에 있습니다. 어,
플랫폼 섹터 네이버가 부진했고 나머지
종목들은 보합 총도 수준이었고요.
니케이 지수가 0.6%가랑 6%가랑
상승 마감했습니다.
국내은 조금 뭐 달랐던 거 같기도
한데 대체로 여기 IT 종목들은 다
좋았습니다. 도쿄 일렉트론 2%
그리고 디스코 4% 이비뎀 8%
무라타가 한 4% 오르면서 뭐
MLCC 기판 장비 다 좋았습니다.
현대차 쪽 자동차 보면 현대차 좀
부진했고요.
기약가 2.5% 5% 오르면서 조금
차별하이 나타나긴 했는데 현대차도
지금 열배까지 떨어져 있는
상황이라서이 수급이 한 번쯤 들어올
때도 되지 않았나 약간 그런 생각도
들긴 합니다. 소비 섹터 봐 주시면
LG 생건 아모레 코스맥스
코스메카코리아
대용화장품과 OEM ODM 업체들
상당히 좋았었고요. 확실히 코스메카
코리아가 좀 더 강한 흐름이
나타났습니다. 피부 미용 기기 섹터
보면 클래시스, 휴젤, APR 어
PV 미용 기기도 최근에 수급 틀이
조금씩 계속 들어오는 거 같아요.
그리고
파마리서치가 상대적으로 좀 최근 흐름
보면 좀 더 강한 거 같아요. 어제는
뭐 1% 오르긴 했지만
휴용 기기 내에서 최근 흐름은 좀
가장 좋지 않나 생각이 들고요. 아래
음식 섹터는 삼약시품도 모처럼
올라가는 모습이었고 백화점 체인도
나쁘지 않았습니다.
기타 섹터 보면 어제 조선주 흐름
나쁘지 않았고요. 현중이 4% 가량
올랐고 그리고 하나 오션, 하나 엔진
등이 상승세를 보였습니다. 하나
오션은 아침에 공시가 있었는데요.
KDDX 사업 우선 탑자 선정이
됐다고 하 공식화가 됐더라고요.
그래서 지금 NXT 장에서 한
10%가랑
급등하는 상황이 있습니다.
>> KDDX가 뭡니까?
>> 국내 군남 프로젝트.
>> 국내 군난 프로젝트. 음. 그래서
이제 현대중업 하나 오션 이렇게
경쟁이었는데요. 원래 하나 오션
쪽으로 갈 거라는 이야기는 뭐
지난해부터 많긴 했는데 거의 뭐
확정적으로 오늘 공식화되다 보니
주가가 모멘텀을 좀 받은 거
같습니다.
>> 그래서 오른쪽에 조선주들의
밸류에이션도 보면
20배 미만에서 다 거래되고
있잖아요. 그래서 어 [콧방귀]
올해부터 그리고 내년 대후년까지 이제
고가 물량들의 조선 배들이 수출이
나가게 되는데 밸류는 20배 미만이고
이익 성장도 대체로 다 P지 개념으로
보면 지금 다 1 미만으로 떨어졌을
거거든요. 뭐 그런 관점으로 보면
상승 여력이 좀 열려 있다라는 생각이
들고
>> 아래 방산주들의 흐름도 좋았습니다.
하나 여로 그저 개인가 제 100만
원 깨지는 거 보고 아 100만 원이
깨지네라고 생각을 했었는데 바로
다음날 어제 이제 반등세가 좀
강했고요. 넥스 현대 로템도
강했습니다. 여기도 뭐 특별한 이슈
없었습니다. 밸류가 낮아지다 보니
순남매 놀 때 강한 상승세를 보였던
거 같고요. 아래 바이오섹터들은 뭐
혼자세였던 거 같습니다. 올랐던
종목도 있고 좀 빠졌던 종목도
있었고요. 증권주 쪽에서 키움 증권이
1.3% 3% 가량 상승세를
보였습니다. 어, 최근에 나온
리포드들을 좀 몇 개 읽어 보니까 뭐
저희도 이제 이전에 얘기했다시피 한국
한
한국 투자 증권에서의 어 키 증권의
점유를 좀 가져가고 있다. 이런
이야기들도
>> 좀 있고요. 근데 또 어떤
리포트들에서는 그런 이야기들도
하더라고요. 지금 거래대금이 어느
정도 픽아웃에 대한 이야기도 좀
나오는 거 같고 그래서 최근에
증권조들의 주가가 많이 내려왔는데
>> 어제 나온 리포트들 보니까 뭐 그런
노이즈들이 이미 다 반영된 수준까지
주가가 많이 내려온 거 같다. 뭐
이런 리포트들이 있더라고. 그래서
최근에 많이 빠진 주가가 어느 정도
회복할 수 있을지 지켜봐야 될 거
같고 엔터 쪽도 어제 특별한 이슈
없었는데 대체로 다 반등 성공을
했습니다. 그리고 변합기 쪽이 상당히
좋았는데요. 현대 1 효성 중공 LS
1렉은 또 10% 가량 등세
보였습니다. 최근에 그 스레이터
보니까 LS 대전반 쪽이 되게
좋더라고.음 음.
알겠습니다. 어저께 이렇게 업종별로
저도 이렇게 관심 종목을 좀 묶어
놨는데 강산 쪽은 특별히 뉴스가 좀
있었습니까? 어땠습니까?
>> 어 전혀 없었었고 개별적인 뉴스도
아예 없었던 거 같고 근데
>> 음
>> 글로벌하게 방산주들이 많이
빠졌었거든요. 특히 유럽에 있는
방산주들. 근데 유럽 방산주들이
조금씩 반등하는 모습이 나오고 있어서
>> 어 그런 관점에서 바닥 잡는 매수세가
유입된 거 같습니다.
>> 음. 큰틀에서 주가가 너무 많이
빠지면 그 기업이 아무리 펀더멘탈이
후져도
>> 사실은 기술적 반등이라는 건 늘
있거든요.
>> 이제 그런 거
어 아주 단순화시켜서 얘기하자면 PG
개념으로 아 이렇게 이익 성장이
있는데 멀티플이 여기까지 빠지나라고
하는 기업들도 반등이 나옵니다.이 이
전자랑 후자는 분명히 다른 건데이
전체적으로 이렇게 봤을 때 업종이나
뭐 이런 것들 좀 후자 개념으로 이런
것들 너무 많이 빠지지 않았나는 거는
좀 전에 이제 조선주 설명해 주셨듯이
또 어떤 업종들이 좀 보이세요?
>> 결국에는 이제 반도체 쉴 때 아니면
반도체 박스로 가거나 하락으로
전환했을 때 어떤 섹터를 담아야
되냐라는 고민과 같은 질문으로 연결해
볼 수 있을 것 같은데요.
>> 음. [목을 가다듬음] 어, 저는
후자 말씀하신 그 PG 1 미만으로
떨어진 기업들이
저는 그냥 방산 조선이 일단 대표적인
거 같고요. 그리고 음식료로 넘어가면
삼양시품 같은 회사. 피 미용 기기도
뭐 파마리서치나 APR 이런
회사들이이 많이 저렴해진 상황이다라고
>> 보고 있는데 반도체 랠리 저 이전에
뭐가 좋았었냐라고 보면 수출 모멘텀
받아서 올라갔던 피우 비용 방산 조선
변합기 뭐 요런 거였잖아요. 물론
변합기는 이제 AI의 엮겨서가 계속
같다라고 볼 수 있지만 그래서 저는
>> 결국에 이번에 반도체가 쉬고 만약
주도주가 잠깐이라도 뭐 딴 데로
간다라고 하면 실적 탄탄하고 밸류
낮아진 조선 방산 여기가 가장
>> 좋지 않을까 그런 생각이 듭니다.
알겠습니다.
오늘은 리포트로 좀 조금 더 이른
시간으로 넘어가 보려고 하는데요.
월초라 수출입 통계 보겠습니다.네
네. 수출입 동향이 나왔는데요.
산업통산 전부에서 매달 나오는
자리고요. 수출 실적 먼저 보면 전년
동월 대비 70.9% 9% 증가한
102억 달러가 나왔습니다. 수입은
30% 증간 660억 달러 나오면서
무역 수치 흑자를 계속해서 기록 중에
있고요. 반도체 쪽 코멘트가 있었는데
메모리 수염이 가격 상승세 지속
중으로 월계 기준 사상 최대 수출
실적을 기록을 했다. 가격 측면으로
보면
전널 대비 상승폭은 완화가 됐는데요.
디램과 랜드 모두 상승세 자체는
지속이 됐다. 주요 메모리 제품 고정
및 증감률
어 참고해서 봐 주시면 될 거
같고요. 수요가 견조한 가운데 고정
가격 상승으로 수출 단가도 증가하면서
월 기준 역대 최대 실적을 달성을
했다라고 볼 수가 있고요. 반도체
수출단가를 보면 20년 4 5 6
이렇게 나오는데요. kg당
어 디램이 5.4 4 만 달러.
그리고 어 4월 달 5.4만
달러였고요. 5월 달 6.1 6월
달에 6만 달러가 나왔습니다. 그래서
>> 좀 내렸네.
>> 네. 디램 쪽 가격이 조금 내려오는
모습이 나타나는데 어제 애널리스트분
킥 코멘트들 보니까 6월 말경에 좀
저가 물량들의 나품이 좀 집중돼서
나갔었다. 6월 말자로. 그런 부분이
가격에 영향을 미쳤던게 아니냐라고
코멘트를 좀 보긴 했습니다.
>> 반면에 랜드 쪽은 확실히 되게 좋은
여전히 계속 좋은 흐름인데요. 4.6
5.7 6점이 해서 랜드는 여전히
견조한 모습이 나타났던 거 같습니다.
컴퓨터 SSD 쪽인데요.
미국을 중심으로 글로벌 데이터 센터
수요가 크게 늘어나고 있고 베라루빈
양산 예정 등 AI 서버나 수요가
확대가 되고 있다. 그래서 5개월
연속 세 자릿수 증가율을 기록 중에
있다라고 하고요. 컴퓨터 수출액으로
보면 26월 26년 2월 26억
달러, 3월 34, 4월 41, 5월
42억, 6월 54억 달러 계속해서
증가흐름이 나타나고 있고요. 아래는
수출액 및 수출 증감률 추인데요.
수출액이 계속해서 올라가고 있는
상황이고 수출 증감률도 뭐 계속해서
올라갑니다. 또 심지어 기울기가 계속
높아지고 있는 상황으로 볼 수가
있는데 Y와Y와Y기 때문에 이런
모습이 나타난다라고 볼 수 있겠고요.
어 오른쪽으로 넘어가서 보면 6월
20대 주요 품목별 수출액인데 뭐
반도체 역대 순위 1위 기록을 했고
YY로 뭐 200% 정도 증가하는
모습이고요. 컴퓨터 쪽 SSD 이쪽
봐 주시면 여기도 역대 1위에 YY
308%
증가하는 모습이 나타났습니다.
자동차도
좀 좋게 나왔던 거 같아요. 그래서
역대순이 1위를 기록했다라고 볼 수
있고요. 그 외에 뭐 참고해 볼 만한
거는 석유 제품이나 뭐 전력 전기
전기 기기 그리고 농수품 화장품 쪽이
또 괜찮은 흐름이었던 거 같습니다.
화장품은 뭐 되게 좋은 거 같아요.
Yy로 42% 증가했으니까 전반적인
업항 자체 나쁘지 않다 볼 수 있을
것 같고요. 아래는 반도체 수출액 및
증감률 주인데요.
YY로 여전히 굉장히 높은 성장률을
기록 중에 있죠. 저희가 반도체 수출
yy 증감률이 언제 꺾이는지 기울기가
언제 꺾이는지도 좀 중요하게 보는
편인데
일단 뭐 7 8 9 작년 대비로는
계속해서 일단 좋을 거 같긴 하고요.
세자리 수 이상 유시될 것으로 보이고
뭐 내 12월로 가서 봐도 제자리
수증간은 기대가 될 거 같거든요.
그래서 올해는 뭐 하반기 증가율
자체가 꺾이지는 않지 않을까? 음,는
생각이 좀 들었고요. 어, 구대 주요
지역별 수출액 및 증감률로 보면
중국, 미국, 인도, 아세안, 이후
역대 다 1위를 기록하는 모습이었고
일본 쪽은 3위 정도 기록했던 거
같습니다. 뭐 전체로 보면 역대 순위
1위 실적이라고 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다.
>> 우선요 보여 주신네 가지 표 중에
제가 궁금한 것만 먼저 짧게 여쭤보고
넘어가 보겠습니다. 왼쪽 위에 보면
수출행 및 수출 증가율 추위 이렇게
막대 그래프가 있는데 막대 그래프
색깔이 조금씩 다르죠. 이게 무슨
의미가 있는 건가요? 부사장님
그렇습니까?
>> 음. 모르겠어요.
>> 그죠? 이게 연별로 끄는 거 같지도
않고.
>> 아. 아.
>> 그렇다고. 어. 이게 증감을이
색깔로 표현한 거 같지도 않고 잘
모르겠네요.
>> 네. 혹시 우리 채밀턴 분들 아시면
저 좀 알려 주시고요.
>> 어. 그 오가장한테 저 하나만 좀
확실하게 물어보고 넘어가고 싶은데
저도 막연히이 모닝 브리프를 제가
참여하지만 밖에서 들으면이
수출 증감률이 9월 정도는 눕는다.
이게 제 머릿속에 확 박혀 있는데 어
위에 보면 위에 그 왼쪽 위에 표
보면은 어 작년 3분기 정도부터이
기울기가 가팔라져 있으니까 제가 갖고
있었던 그 기억이 맞는 거 같아요.
그런데 밑에 반도체 수출만 보면 또
우리 오과장 얘기처럼 이렇게 세 자리
수장한 거는 올해부터기 때문에 어
12월까지는 또 아주 높은 성장률처럼
보일 수 성장률을 보일 수 있겠다
이렇게 그 나뉘어져 생각이 좀 드는데
그러면 우리가 9월 정도부터는 좀
누을 수 있겠다라고 얘기한 건 전체
수출 통계를 그동안 얘기하고 있었던
건가요?
>> 네. 그렇게 이해하시면 될 거
같고요. 일단 반도체는
일단 하반기까지는 뭐 너무나 좋을 거
같기는 한데
>> 음
>> 어 뭐 개별 기업의 기울기 측면으로
보면 전자나 하이닉스의 하반기 QQ
아 MOM이나 QQ 이익 증가를 보면
눕는게 아니라 쭉 떨어지거든요.
>> 음.
>> 네.이 이 증가율로만 보면 수출
데이터는 전체적인 이런 흐름을 보는
거고 저희가 투자 측면으로 연결해서
보려면 기울기가 어쨌든 중요한 건데
전자나 닉스나 다 한 자리 수로
떨어질 것으로 추정이 됐거든요.
>> 언제쯤부터
>> 4분기입니다.
>> 4분기
>> 3분기까지는 그래도 한 [콧방귀]
>> 2분기가 80% 60% 정도고
3분기간 30%로 떨어지는 걸로 알고
있거든요. 이제 기울기는 떨어지는
이런 상황에서
어 하필도 이제 메타의 그런 이슈나
노이즈 그리고 단기적으로 모멘텀으로
너무 반등이 약 주가가 강하게 올랐던
>> ETF 레버리지 출시 그리고 ADR
상장
>> 음
>> 이런 것들이
>> 주가 상승 속도를 너무 가파르게
만들어서
>> 음
>> 거기에 따른
>> 좀 회개하는 과정이 좀 필요하지 않
그런 생각이 들어서 어쨌든이 지금
수출 증감률로만 보고 뭔가 판단
판단하기는
>> 되게 어렵다라고 본게 맞는 거
같고요. 차라리 개별 기업 반도체는
이제 개별 기업으로 들어와서
>> 이익의 증가율이나 이런 걸 보는게 좀
더 투자에는 도움이 되지 않을까
싶어.
>> 네. 그렇죠. 바텀업으로 개별
기업단에서 우리가 좀 더 면밀히 봐야
하는데 윤상님 좀 전에 오가장 얘기해
주셨던
>> 가격이 조금 빠졌어요.
>> 그 부분은 어쨌든 좋은 뉴스는 아닌
거 같은데
>> 그냥 지나가야 할 뉴스인가요? 우리가
좀 심각하게 봐야 할 뉴스인가요?
사실 뭐 반도체를 크로그램당으로
계단하진 않거든요.
>> 예. 이거는 창고 지표로 그냥 보시고
그리고 분기 단위로 보시는게 더 좋을
것 같습니다. 11단 20일단위 월관
단위보다는 분기 단위가 변동성을 좀
줄일 수 있는 그런 맥락일 것
같습니다.
>> 음.
>> 알겠습니다. 그러면 우리 오장님 수출
관련 수출입 통계 관련해서 준비해
주신 자료 여기까지입니까?
>> 네.
>> 네. 다음 리포트로 넘어가 볼
텐데요. 오랜만에 엔터인데 뭐 오래
전에 우리 오과장한테 제가 한번
물어본 적 있는 거 같은데 다시 한번
물어보겠습니다. 요즘에는 기업 리포트
내일 이거 말씀드려야겠다 할 때 한
몇 개쯤 정도 보고 또 정하십니까?
>> 요즘 진짜 잘 안 봅니다. 아,
그니까 볼게 없습니다.
>> 어,
>> 리포트가
>> 안 본다는 거랑 볼게 없다는 건 천지
차이야.
>> 그 리포트들이 잘 안 나와. 개별주에
대한 리포트
>> 엔터도 최근에 뭐 하이브 리포트 이런
거 보면 한 3주 전이 마지막
>> 음
>> SM YG 이런 것도
>> 산업 리포트는 간강히 나오는데요.
>> 워낙 이게 소외되다 보니 아마
연구님들도
뭐 법인 같은 데서 이제 세미나 요청
이런 것도 확 줄어든 걸로 알고
있어요. 저번에
>> 어 세미나도 한번 했었는데 거의
요청이 없다고 하더라고. 그러다 보니
물리포트도 조금 시험 시험 쓰시는 거
같고 해서
>> 대형 뭐 반도체 AI 밸류체인에 엮겨
있는 업종을 제외하고 리포트들이 많이
안 나오더라고.
>> 제가 아침마다 가져오는 것도 맨날
똑같은 IT 종목 반도체 이런 것만
가져왔었는데
>> 다 이유가 있었어. 네. 그런
>> 흐름이 있었던 거 같고요. 근데 이제
또 개별주들이 만약 좀 살아나기
시작한다면 다시
>> 이런 엔터나 다른 쪽도 리포트들이 좀
많이 나올 수 있지 않을까? 음라는
생각이 듭니다. 엔터 쪽 리포트 좀
말씀드리면 전체에 말도 안 되는
저평가 구간에 놓여져 있다라고 하나
이기운 연구원이 코멘트를 남겼는데요.
짧은 리포트였습니다. 예상했던 기간
조정보다 더 가파른 가격 조정으로
강한 비중 확대를 추천한다라고
하는데요. AI에 집중된 수급 이슈
등으로 주가가 상당히 부진했는데
2분기 실적은 대체로 컨센 정도 나올
것으로 보고 있다. 부진한 회사 역시
하방이 높은 실적 모멘텀이 예상이
된다라고 하고요. 5세대인 코르티즈나
캐치하인은 역사를 바꿀 속도로 성장
중에 있다라고 하고이는 경진 그룹의
성장에도 긍정적인 영향을 미칠
전망이다. 예상했던 기간 조정보다 더
가파른 가격 조정이 나타났기 때문에
비중확대 기회를 우리가 활용해
보자라는 의견이고요. 주가는 하이브
22배 SMJPY 각각 한 12배에서
15배 정도에 거래가 되고 있다라고
해서 상당히 좀 저평가 수준이다라고
해석을 했고요. 2분기 실적은 하이브
SM 부합 JPYG는 화해할 것으로
추정을 했습니다. 하이브는 BTS의
역사적인 월드투어로 사상 최대 실적이
예상이 된다라고 하고요. SM도
NCT 위시나 라이즈 에스파가 동반
컴백하면서 호실적이 예상이 된다. 어
JP는 좀 부진할 것으로 보는데요.
하반기 스트레이지 컴백 어 대규
투어로 사성 최대 실적을 하반기 중에
좀 나오지 않을까 전망을 했고
와이즈도 8월부터 빗 20주년 투엄인
연내 신인 남자 그룹의 대비를 준비
중에 있다라고 합니다. 4이브 실적에
대한 우려소는 매우 긍정적인데 BT
사상 최대 BTS의 사상 최대 실적
선반형 및 평만한 아우의 부제로
불과네 달 만에 섹터 주가가 40에서
50% 하락세를 기록을 했습니다.
하이브 주가는 역사적 저점인 예상
배수인 30배도 30% 하여야는
2배까지 빠져 있고요. 나머지 3사도
저점 15배를 뚫고 SM 기준
10배까지 하락을 그랬습니다. 이런
극단적인 저평가를 해소하기 위해선
단기적으로는 BTS의 분배율 우려가
있는 하이브의 2분기 실적이 상당히
중요해졌는데요.
해외 언론을 통해 45, 5월 누적
투어 매출액이 발표되는 등 높은
기대치에 부합하지 않을까라는 전망을
했고이는 하반기 실적 전망에도 높은
안정감을 줄 전망이다. 그래서 5세대
쪽은 가파르게 성장 중에 있다라고
하고요. 어틴은 이미 내년 2분기부터
여덟 명의 멤버가 활동 가능한
수준으로 근대 이슈가 해소될 예정이고
하이브가 반등한다면 탁 기획사들도
동반 상승할 것으로 예상을 한다.
전망을 했습니다. 저희 아래는
밸루에이션 테이블인데요.
맨 위 어 파란색 선이 하이브고
어 그다음 하얀색이 JP 빨간색 SM
보라색이 Y엔터
입니다. 그래서 밸루에이션이
아까 용구원님이 말한 대로 지금
하이브는 저점 밸류까지 내려앉은
상황이고요.
뭐 다른 업 다른 기업들은 더 심한
거 같아요. 뭐 SM은 열배를 찍고
조금 반등에 성공을 했고요. 어,
비슷한 흐름인 거 같아요. 제 한
13배 정도. 아, YG가 13배.
그리고
한 12배 정도의 거래가 되고 있기
때문에 굉장히 낮은 밸류로 모든
엔터사들이 거래가 되고 있다. 그래서
사실 한 15배 정도에
거래됐을 때도 이런 비슷한 류의
리포트가 나왔었거든요. 근데 그
리포트 나와서 하루 반등하더니 또
반도체 쪽으로 수급 쏠리 쏠려가고
열배 초반까지 빠진 상황이거든요.
지금 밸루에이션은 매우 매력적인
구간은 맞다. 근데 한 가지 체크해야
될 점은 결국 하이브가 살아야 되는데
2분기 실적에서 이제 BTS 실적이
온기 다 반영이 되기 때문에 분배율이
어떻게 됐을지 알 수 있다. 그래서
만약에 분배가 그렇게 됐음에도 실적이
좋다라고 하면은 하이브가 본격적으로
반등을 할 수 있을 거고 1등주가
반등하게 되면 결국엔 JP, SM,
YG 어 따라갈 가능성이 좀 있다라고
좀 생각이 듭니다.
네. 수고하셨습니다.
어
증권사 P비분들하고
함께이 웨비나가 있어 가지고요. 조금
전에 웨비나 끝내고 다시
들어왔습니다.
어 위에 수출입 동량 데이터이 되게
중요한 부분인데요. 오늘 월간 전망
자료 저녁에 촬영할 때도이 수출액 및
수출 증검 추의 이거 보여 드릴
거거든요. 우리나라 코스피는이 수출
증검률라고 똑같이 움직이 된다고 보면
돼요. 그래서 24년 25년
상반기까지
우리나라 주식 20 뭐 23년 앞에도
보이지는 않지만 수천 증감률이
없었거든요. 23년에는 반도체가 뭐
적장할 때라 가지고 그래서 아
우리나라 장은 안 되나 봐. 국장
탈출 얘기했었던 이유도 수출
증감이에서 뚜렷한 뭐가 없었어요.
근데 25년부터이
수출 정률이 하반기부터 급등하지
않습니까?이 이 부분을 주가가
선반영하면서 움직했고 수출 증검률에
가장 큰 영향을 주는 거는 뭐니머니도
반도체 그죠?이 반도체가 448억
달러인데 다른 거 자동차 67억 달러
뭐 기계 40억 석유화 40억 50억
반도체가 차지하는 부분이 전체
102억 달러에서 448억 달러니까
그죠?
>> 예. 거의 뭐 45% 가까이 되고
>> 그게 우리나라 지금 삼성전자
하이닉스가 전체 시총에서도 50%
넘잖아요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 그런 부분이 정확하게 이제
반영이 되 있는데 저 수출 정갑률은
그러면 언제 꺾일까?
언제 꺾일까는
어 좀 전에 우리 박성구 매니저가
만들어 준 자료에 보면 결국은 반도체
증감률이 꺾여야 되거든요. 그 반도체
증감률은 언제 꺾이냐면 9월 10월
넘어가면서부터이
기고 효과가 나타나면서
기저에서 저가 낮을 저는 아니지만 네
>> 그래서 작년 9월 이후로 반도체
가격이 급등을 했었기 때문에이 수출
증감률도 올해 9월 10월 지나가면
이제 좀 꺾이는 모습이 나오게 될
거고 코스피도 그러면서 저는 이제
박스피로 어 올 하반기부터 내년으로
그렇게 박스피로 갈 가능성이 높은데
2012년부터
15년까지 그 박스피 기구간 동안에
엄청난 종목장이었다고 제가
말씀드렸잖아요.
그런 장이 연출이 될 거고 결론 그
웨비나에서 제가 말씀드렸던 결론은 어
결국 이번에는 예전에는 내가 집을
샀냐 안 샀느냐 그게 중요했다면 이번
장애는 주식을 했냐 안 했냐 그게
중요할 건데이
모멘텀으로 지금 움직이는이 주도주
공략을이 잘못하면 이번이 반도체가
움직이 전에는 조방 조방원부터
시작했다는 거죠. 조방원 피부 미용
엔터부터 시작을 했고 그다음에
반도체가 보면 증감률이 199% 나온
거죠. 이번 달에도 6월 달. 그래서
워낙 증감률이이 컴퓨터 308% 다른
것들은 증갑률이 괜찮긴 한데
18.8% 17%
49% 이런 것들이 아유 야 눈에도
안 들어온다는 거죠.
그런데 반도체 증갑률이 이제 저
기울기가 이렇게 완만하게 되면
반도체는 이제 박스권으로 그래서
박스권으로 들어가면 약간은 지금까지는
추세 추종형 전략을 썼다면 이제부터는
역발상 전략을 내년까지는 잘 이용을
해야 된다.
>> 음. 그렇게 전략을 저희가 말씀드렸고
그다음에이 박스권으로 들어갔을 때
뭐가 튀어오를까 보면 답은 사실 다
정해져 있어요. 내년 내 5년까지
확실한 이익 성장 확실한 이익 성장이
있는 곳은 어딘가 그런 걸 이제
찾아가면서
투자를 하는 그냥 내 후년 초까지나
아무튼 참 주식으로 저희 고객분들도
자산이 엄청 늘어났잖아요. 그죠?
네. 많이 늘어났습니다.
>> 3년 동안에 정말 큰 폭으로
늘어났는데
오죽하면 2년 전에 집이 [콧방귀]
집을 저 그때 못 사서 어 스트레스
받는다 하신 분이 이번에 오셨어도
집안 사도 될 거 같은데요. 딱 그
말씀 아셨어요. 그죠?
>> 집안 사도이 정도 수익률이면 집안
사도 될 거 같은데
그런 장이 내 5년 초까지 계속
이어진다라고 보시면 될 거 같아.
자, 그다음에 엔터테인먼트이 리포트에
말도 안 되는 저평가 구간이라고 돼
있잖아요. [목을 가다듬음]
>> 네.
>> 그래서 어, 저희가 [콧방귀]
최근에도 1임이나 랩이나 계속 하는
이유가 말도 안 되게 저평가돼 있는
주식들이 너무 많아요. 근데 왜 말도
안 되게 빠졌냐? 반도체가 너무
좋으니까.
>> 음.
>> 예. 그래서 반도체 좋을 때는 반도체
붙어서 매매하고 반도체의 기울기가
이제 좀 꺾인다 싶으면 그다음에는 또
말도 안 되는 저런 저평가 주식이 막
튀어 올라올 겁니다.
그렇게 이제 보시면 되고 어제 창에
이제 메탄 요런 부분들이 말이 좀
있었는데
저희 아들이
기국을 했잖아요. 아들이 이번에
포엑스에서 AI 뭐 관련해서 발표가
있어서 들어온 건데
>> 아들이 얘기해 준 거에서 중요한
얘기를 제가 어제 전에 들었는데 어
우리는 이제 그 엔비디아의
레라루빈이나 이런 걸 보면서 야 이거
뭐 수요가 AI 인프라 투자에 지금
전부 메타부터 해 가지고 엄청나게
돈질을 하고 있었잖아요. 설사 과잉
투자를가
되더라도 지금은 과잉 투자가 덜
위험하다.이 얘기하면서 2년 동안
진러댔잖아요.
>> 음.
>> 근데 지금이 어떤 상황이냐면 딱 그
얘기를 하더라고요. 그
AI 인프라를 질러 놓은 쪽에서 지금
아주 극단적으로 얘기하면 5%밖에
활용을 못 하고 있다.
>> 음.
유틸라이션이라는 용어를 썼니까
>> 생각에 우리는 이제 여기 지금까지
투자해 놨던 것도 꽉 차서
>> 계속 더 투자를 해야 된다라고 알고
있잖아요.
>> 예예.
>> 근데 AI 하드웨어, AI 소프트웨어
>> 이런 관점에서 봤을 때 AI 하드웨어
쪽에 대한 인프라 투자를 최첨단으로
막 계속 질러 놨는데
>> 예.
활용이 유틸라이제이션 그래서 야 이거
왜 좀 활용해서 이제 돈 벌어야 되는
거 아니야? 그 일안의 하나가 지금
메타에이 유유 그 클라우드를 유유에
데이터 센터에 유 [목을 가다듬음]
설비를 어 클라우드로 좀 해야
됩니다.
네.
>> 그러면 어 빅테크도 모자하기 때문에
네오 클라우드 밑에서 네오
클라우드조차도 야 빅테크 꽉 찼으니까
그래서 네오 클라우드 업체가 또 해도
수요가 있어야 되잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 그 네오 클라우드가 왜 박살이 나냐면
>> 어 빅테크가 질러난 쪽이 풀 케파가
아니라 어 남아돌아. 어 그러면
네오클라우드 쓸 필요가 없어지는
거예요.
그러면서 네오클라우드가 박살이 그게
그 논리가 맞다면 지금
유틸라이제이션이
어 100% 돌아가는게 아니라 너무
과잉 투자가 돼 있는 상황이다.
>> 음
>> 그 논리도 싸지만 네오클라우드 주가가
박살이 나음
>> 그렇죠. 예. 하여튼 그런 개념으로
시장이 이번에 저는 이렇게 하루 만에
>> 그 얘기를 저는 전해들은지 하루만에
이렇게 시장이 반응을 할 줄
몰랐는데요
>> 개념은 우리 채밀던 분들도 한번
고민을 해 보시고 그쪽 분야에 계시는
분들도 많잖아요. 에 계시는 분들도
그런 부분에 대한이
검정을 한번 다같이 해 보셔.
자, 그렇게 보면 되고요.
오늘 시장은 지금 어떻게 되고
있습니까?
>> 네. 시장 -4.46%로
하락해서 출발했고요. 현재
-5.34%로
하락폭 좀 더 키워서 하락하고
있습니다.
>> 네.
>> 시작부터 8,이 깨졌어 시작요.
7,850 가고 있고 코스닥은
어떻습니까?네
>> 코스닥 -2.67%로
하락해서 출발했었고요. 현재
-4%입니다.
>> 거기다가 어제 10년물 국제 금리가
좀 또 위로
튀었고 그죠? 4.4 다시 넘어갔죠.
>> 예. 4. 1.4p
있습니다.
>> 유가가 저러면 좀 10년 극적금니다.
툭툭 떨어지면 되는데
>> 지금 앞으로 3개월 전략을 월반
전방에서도 말씀드리겠지만
>> 지금 7월 달에 발표될 6월에
CPI가 4.0 정도로 떨어지는 걸로
그렇게 다들 예상하고 있잖아요.
>> 근데 6월 CPI 있거든요. 월드컵
특수로 아들한테도 물어봤지만 공황이
바글바글하다는 거죠.
>> 음.
>> 미국은 우리는 이제 도로가
바글바글하며 야, 어디 놀러 많이
가는구나. 그렇게 할 수 있는데
미국은 공황을 가고 할 수 있는데
바글바글하기 때문에 6월 달 CPI가
4.0이 나올까? 저는
>> 음.
>> 오히려 안 떨어질.
>> 음. 그렇게 해서 4.0
나올 걸로 생각했는데 4.1 4.2
이
>> 요렇게 나와 버리면 7월 29일 날
야 이거 금리 올려야 되는 거 아니?
>> 네. 그게
시장에 여러 가지로 또
>> 주제심이라고 할 수 있게는 그런
요인이 될 건데
>> 8월에 발표되는 7월 CPI, 9월에
발표되는 8월 CPI는 이제 유가가
한 두 달 래깅이 있기 때문에
그때부터는 PPI도 툭툭 떨어지고
>> 예. CPI도 떨어지고 고용도 안
좋게 나오고.
>> 음.
>> 그러면서 10년물 국정 겁니까? 9월
언절이 되면 4.2에서
4.0 4.0 살짝 깰 수도 있지
않을까?
>> 예. 그러면서 오히려 9월 달이 늘
장이 안 좋았는데 오히려 이번에는 좀
미리 매맞고
>> 8월 말에서 9월 넘어가면서부터는
오히려
>> 그런 모습을 전체적으로 생각을 하고
있습니다. 그러니까 오늘 하락도 보면
아 이거 어떤 사람들은 그런 얘기
많이 하잖아요. 반도체 끝나면 장이
끝난다고
>> 그거는 아닙니다.
반도체로 시작한 장도 아니었고
고금리에서 하여튼 실적 잘 나오는
기업들 조방 피부 미용 엔터 시작하고
반도체가 좋으면 또 반도체로 가고
실적이 좋은 쪽으로는 계속 자금이
수납 매매가 돌아가는 그런 장일 거기
때문에 너무 한쪽으로 이제
맹목적으로네
반도체 끝나면 장 끝난 거다. 그렇게
또 너무 생각하셔도
자
미국 시장은 어제 다 반등을 예상을
했었는데 그죠? 예, 빠졌는데
>> 예,
>> 오늘은 어떻게 될 것 같습니까? 이게
바로 빠지고 바로 반발 매수가
들어갈지 아니면 이게 추가적으로
하락이 이어질지
>> 요게 이제 다들 걱정이 있을 건데
유리프로는 어떻게 생각해요?
>> 잠깐만. 오늘 밤이 오전장하고 이제
끝나는 거예요?
>> 예, 그렇습니다. 어,
>> 그 오후 1시까지 합니다.
>> 오후 1시까지
>> 예. 예. 미국 6시간. 어, 그리고
금요일은 장이 없습니다.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 그리고 어제 우리 이역구장님이 적어
놓으셨잖아요. 6월에 고점 친적은
1950년 이후로 한 번도 없었다.
>> 음.
>> 그래서 어제 시장 보시면 어,
반도체는 빠지는데 빅테크
하이퍼스러들이 확 올라오잖아요.
>> 음.
>> 예. 그 부분이 아까 우리 채부장님이
하이퍼스켈레들의 그 케펙스
>> 어 추정치 있잖아요.
>> 근데이 추정치도 우리가 좀 잘 생각해
봐야 되는게 추정치가 최근에 계속
올라갔잖아요.
>> 예.요
>> 부분이 데이터 센터를 하나 지려고
했는데 야 이거 두 개가 필요해서 두
개를 짓고 세 개를 짓고의 개념이
아니라
>> 음
>> 비용이 증가하다 보니까
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 네. 야, 이거 원래는 500억 달러
생각했는데 야, 500억 달러도 안
되겠네. 왜냐면 뭐 저장 장치
ESSD부터 다 올랐으니까. 그래서
최근에 케펙스 상향 추위는 가격이
오은 거를 반영을 해서 올린
거거든요. 근데 나중에 가격이
떨어지면 이게 약간 또 반대로
도미노처럼 투자심을 악화시킬 수 있는
게
>> 반도체 스팟 가격이 떨어지고 고정거래
가격이 떨어지고 이러면서 가격이
떨어지면 그다음 케팩스 가이든스에서는
어 케팩스 저번에 900억 달러로
했는데 어
>> 800억 달러
>> 예
>> 예 가격이 떨어져서 오히려 투자
비용이 줄어드는 건데 야 이제 AI
인프라 투자 사이클 끝난 거 아니야?
또 이렇게 막 해석을 할 가능성이 또
있네. 맞습니다. 정확합니다.
>> 그래서 어 그 메타가 그 케펙스
추정치로 올린 것도 그 뒤에 이제
해석을 보면은 메타 스스로도 어
반도체 가격이 너무 올랐기 때문에
우리는 케펙스 비용을 올릴 수밖에
없다라고 어 추가적으로 설명을
했거든요. 예. 말씀하신게
정확합니다.
>> 예.
그러다 보니까이 반도체 가격이
떨어지면이
하이프 스케일러들 입장에서는이
[목을 가다듬음]
오퍼레이션
캐시플로 영업 현금 흐름에서 케펙스를
뺀게 순 현금 흐름이 되는 건데
>> 케펙스 부담이 이제 줄어드니까
>> 당연히 주주 환원을 할 수 있는
순영업 현금 흐름이 현금 흐름이
>> 커질 거고 그럼 주가가 당연히
그렇습니다. 올라가는 그런 모습이 될
거기 때문에 미국 시장 전체적으로는
보면 오히려 어 올라갈 가능성이 높은
거예요. 시종이거는
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 예. M7들이
그런 개념으로 뭐 앨런머스크 쪽에
테슬라도 그렇고 다 지금 계속
질러돼야 되잖아요. 휴먼노이드
로봇하기 위해서도 질러야 되고 자율
>> 주행하기 위해서도 계속 이쪽 어
반도체가 필요했던 부분인데 예
반도체가 혹시 꺾인다면 얘네들 주가가
올라가는 거죠.
>> 맞습니다. 예. 그렇게 어 [콧방귀]
시장이 주는 메시지와 내 생각하고
계속 이렇게 검정을 해 보면서 투자를
하다 보니까 주식이 재밌어지는 거죠.
그죠?
>> 예, 그렇습니다. 재미있기도 하고
도전이기도 하고요. 예.
>> 예, 맞습니다.
자, 그러면 국내 아, 그 미국은
어떻게 된다고요? 오늘 밤에는
>> 오늘은 그래도 상승하지 않을까라고
생각은 하는데요. SP는 확실히
상승할 거 같고.
>> 어, 확실하게. 네.
>> 네네.
며칠
>> 일단
>> 내일 아침에 또
저녁에 하면서 아 토요일에 방송
드리면서 또 번복할 가능성도 없잖아
있긴 한데 어찌 됐든 오늘 이제 고용
지표 나오고 그리고 소비 여력이나
이런 부분에 있어서 앞서서 이제
말씀드렸듯이 매크로 쪽이 미국 시장이
괜찮다라고 저는 생각하기 때문에 계속
안에서 이렇게 순환매가 돌다가 돈
버는 쪽을 찾아가면서 그래도 어
수급이 빠지진 않기 때문에 지수
자체는 유지되지 않을 거라고
생각합니다.
>> 유리프로 얼굴을 보면 아이 전망에
대한 상당한 부담감을 갖고 뭔가
얘기를 하는데
>> 실제로 그래요. 우리가이 피드백을
댓글이나 이런 걸로 저는 댓글로 많이
피드백을 봤잖아요. 네가 와 뭐 그때
얘기했는데 틀렸네 뭐 이런 거 뭐
마상하거든. 음.
>> 당연히 그럽니다. 인간인 이상.
>> 그렇죠. [웃음] 인간인 이상.
>> 악불 보면 마상하고 예. 강작가 보면
되게 그냥 자기 방식대로 사는 사람인
거 같은데도 맨 마지막에 그러잖아요.
좋아요를 누르면 저도 좋아하고 안
좋아요를 누르면 싫어요를 누르면
자기도 아주 싫어한다고.
>> 댓글을 보진 않는데. 근데 이제
어제도 예상치 못한 이슈가 터지면서
이렇게 지수가 움직였잖아요.
>> 어 왜 이걸 생각을 못 했지? 이런
건 좀
>> 그렇죠.
>> 우리가 제가 늘 그랬잖아요. 내
IQ는 80 시장큐는 2만이라고
그 2만이기 때문에 우리가 도전을 해
보는 거 아니겠습니까?
>> 그렇죠. 맞습니다. 네. 수학하는
사람들이 그거잖아요.이 난재를 풀려고
막 200년 300년 동안 안 풀린
난재 한번 풀어 보는 것처럼 우리가
주식이 딱 그래 보니까 계속 끊임없이
난재가 나오고 그걸 우리는 풀려고
노력하는 사람이고
>> 풀다가 틀릴 때도 있고 맞출 때도
있는데 맞추면 엄청 기분이 좋아요.
>> 예.
>> 그죠? 그렇습니다. 도파민이
온터집니다.
>> 필반은 어떻게? 아, 필반은 사실
제가 어제 2시에 일어나 가지고
지금까지 보고 있는데음
저는 좀 과잉 반응이었다라고
>> 보고 있고 그래서
>> 어
>> 연휴를 앞두고 좀 사람들의 심리가
나빠질 수도 있겠지만 어제 과잉
반응으로 인해서 오늘은 좀 반등하지
않을까 전 그렇게 생각합니다.
>> 예.
자, 그러니까 독립 기념일을
기념하기 위해서
행사가 존재 중인데 시장을 그죠.
예. 급락하게 다지는 않을 겁니다.
근데 방금 말씀드렸듯이이 다 이게
시소 게임이에요. 시소 게임.
>> 자, 그리고 국내 시장은 어, 지금
코스피 하락률이 더 깊어지고 있는데
코스피는 어떻게 될 것 같습니까?
51 이평선까지 빠졌네. 도시 입편서
깨고 내려가고 있는데 초는 한
4.46으로 시작했었고
오늘 음봉날 가능성이 좀 더 반도체
쪽에 대한
노이즈들이 계속 나오고 있잖아요.
이것저것 그게 뭐 현실화될지 실제로
뭐 기업에 영향을 줄지 이런 거에
대해서 아직 파악하기 힘들지만 좀
>> 센티멘트가 계속 안 좋아지고 있다는
생각이 들어서 오늘은 좀 음봉과
관화성이 좀 더 높다라고
생각이 듭니다.
우리나라 시장의
어 오전장은
시초가부터는
미국 시장을 보면서 움직이고 오후장은
그죠. 오늘 밤 미국 시장을 보면서
움직이는데
>> 네
>> 한 10시까지 매물을 소하고 나중에
>> 반등이 들어갈지
>> 아니면 이대로 밀려서 끝날지
코스닥 또 음봉이에요.
양봉.네
>> 양봉. 아 양봉으로 바뀌었어요.
>> 근데 지금 시초가가 아까 2%
때였네. 네.
>> 2.67%
>> 와 해서 지금 5%까지 빠졌는데
>> 네
>> 밑꼬리 쭉 달고 양봉 날 가능성이네
>> 지금 그렇게 나오고 있고
>> 양봉으로 나온단 말이죠.네
>> 아마 그 과도의 갭 있잖아요. 그것
때문에 아마 좀 정수가 좀 좋았어요.
>> 아 그
>> 갭이요?
응
>> 갭하라 아니면
>> 개 팔아야 됩니다. 그래서 그니
항상은 장하니까
>> 그래서이 개 하던데 그 좀 점수가
좋았어요.
>> 아까
하이브 저거 리포트 얘기했었는데
하이브는 플러스네. 리포트 효과가 좀
있나 봐.
어, 네. 좀 [웃음]
아, 근데 저는 뭐 하이브를
주가를 제가 예상했던 거 너무 다르게
움직였어 가지고
미리 많이 빠졌으니까.
알겠습니다.
음.이
그 볼린저 밴드는 저걸로 보면 어떻게
돼 있어요, 지금? 어,
>> 어디까지 빠질 것 같아? 이
>> 아, 지수요?
>> 네.
>> 잠시만.
진짜 개인 개인적인 생각 건데.
아, 사실 주봉상으로 올린저는
상단을 깨고 내려왔는데
중단을 가는 경우는 거의 없거든요.
이런 추세 최근 추세 그니까 1년
반간의 추세를 보면.
>> 음. 음. 근데 만약 볼린저 중단까지
빠진 다음에 2 7,000 포인트까지
빠져야 되고 저건 좀 아닌 거
같고요. 일봉상으로
보면
한
7,500 정도까지 빠질 수
있습니다.
>> 7,500.
>> 네.
>> 지금 7,800이네요.
일봉상에서 지금 60주 이평선이
있는게 7,400원짜리 와 있군요.
네.
>> 어, 딱 그거 거기랑 비슷합니다.
오랜저는
>> 이은택 연구원이 저번에 이격도
얘기했을 때 그게 50일 이평
대비해서 이격도였어요.
>> 네. 50일 이격이 130%가
넘어가면 조심하죠. 근데 이번에는 못
넘고 내려
120선에서.
그렇죠. 그랬었는데 지난번에 이런
전정태는 급락하고 반등 들어가다가
다시 빠지면서 쌍바닥 채썰 때요
60일 이평 살짝 깨고 겁 한번 주고
>> 그러고 올라왔었다고 그죠.
이번에 시장에 대한 이제 확인을
해보는 시점이 어 7월 말 그래서
저희가 1등 매니저 따라가기를 제가
8월 1일부터 정한 이유가
>> 예네
>> 7월 초 요런 모습이 나오면
>> 시장이
어 어떤 어느 정도에서 또 반발
매수가 강요고
>> 또 아무래도 국민연금의 리밸런싱도 뭐
시작된 부분도 있고 그 외국 외국인
팔고 국민연금 더 팔고 하면 누가 사
주냐는 거죠.
그런데 떨어지면 보통 우리 개인
투자자분들은 떨어지면 이제 매수
공격적으로 들어오기 때문에 지금
투자자 예탁금이 한 140조예
언절이 있고
>> 아직까지도 퇴직 연금 계좌에서 계속이
머니 모브가 이루어지고 있기 때문에
밑으로 떨어지면 떨어질수록 이제 가격
메리트가 생기면서
이격도 조정도 나오 끝나고 나면
그러면 강한 매수세가 이제 들어올
건데 그 부분이 아까 말씀드린 대로
뭐 CPI라든지 그다음에 회대의 금리
인상 여구 예 요런 거에 있어서 좀
불확실성이
좀 남아 있다 보니까
>> 7월이 원래는 전통적으로는 강세장인데
>> 음
>> 이번에는 좀 변동성이 흔들리면 좀
아는 시장이 될 거다라고 생각하는 거
같습니다.
예. 오늘 7월 2일 최선 모림분을
여기까지 하겠습니다. 함께 해 주신
여러분 고맙습니다. 감사합니다.